WELCOME- TO MY COLLEAGUES AND TO
THOSE IN ATTENDANCE AND WATCHING
AND HEARING TODAY- IT IS GOOD TO
BE BACK. DOING THE PEOPLE'S WORK
HEREBY CERTIFY- I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO READ HOLD ON. AND ACTUALLY
BEFORE I GO INTO THIS IF WE
COULD GO AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE IN
ESTABLISH QUORUM. HERE JONES
SAWYER. HERE LACKEY STONE BY
THEIR YEAH
. TWO HUNDRED. OKAY
THANK YOU WE ESTABLISH QUORUM I
GET AFTERNOON BEFORE WE BEGIN I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
EVERYONE HERE WHILE ALLOWING
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TWO THEY WERE HAVING
AN IN PERSON HEARING AT THE
STATE CAPITOL IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. THE PANELISTS ON
THE EDGE AND THE ARE. ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BEGIN WITH THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FOLLOWED BY PHONE
TESTIMONY. EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
UP TO ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT ON THE
COMMITTEE IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING THIS
HEARING. JUST IN CASE THE NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE. FIVE SEVEN.
AGAIN AT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN AGAIN THE PUBLIC AT SIX
ACCESS CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE. TWO SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. WILL NOT BE TAKING
ANY BOTH SITTING. THE SERVER IS
BUT IT'S A FIVE HEARING OF THE
YEAR ONE UP AND THEN MAKE STILL
LOOMS OVER US WE ARE COMMITTED
TO PRESSING BOARD ON THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE WITH THE
PUBLIC SAFETY INVESTMENTS. WE
HAVE MANY IMPORTANT PROPOSALS TO
CONSIDER THIS YEAR AND ENCOURAGE
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS TO SHARE
THEIR INPUT IS SUBMIT LETTERS TO
ADVISE THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND AND
HOW WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT.
OF OUR INVESTMENTS. WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING YET ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET SURPLUS IT IS
HAPPENING IN THE BACKDROP OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT IS STILL IMPACTING
OUR COMMUNITIES FAMILIES
STUDENTS AND WORKFORCE. HAVING A
SERVER SURPLUSES NOT RELIEVE US
OF OUR DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
RESEARCHERS ARE THOUGHT BELIEVE
DIRECTLY AT THEIR ACTED IN A
MANNER THAT ADVANCES THE
INTERESTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED
DETAILED PLANS WERE OUTCOME
DRIVEN MEASURES ARE THE NORM AND
NOT THE- EXCEPTION I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
WILL BE HAVING IN THE BUDGET
SESSION THIS YEAR. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK OUR PARTNERS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THEIR
WORK IN PUTTING TOGETHER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ILLICIT OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE. FOR THEIR
VALUABLE INSIGHT AND ANALYSIS
AND SUPPORT AND TEXT AFTER
HELPING WITH LOGISTICS. OF A
REMOTE HEARING. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
JENNIFER CAMPER FOR CHALICE
TIRELESS EFFORTS AS WELL- BEFORE
I GO INTO ANY OF THE HEARINGS I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WANT TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS TODAY. OKAY
THEN. WITH THAT I DO APPRECIATE
EVERYONE BEING HERE TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED. OUR FIRST ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS A PANEL THAT INCLUDED
IN OUR REVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD. AND
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS DISCUSSION
IS TO HEAR ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THAT WE- WHAT WE ARE DOING WELL
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE SUPPORTING
VICTIMS OF CRIME TO EASE TEIR
AND THEIR FAMILIES BIRD IN THERE
IN A DRAMATIC TIME IN THEIR
LIVES. AS PART OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT AND
AGREEMENT WAS MADE TO
CONSOLIDATE THE LEAST TO
CONSOLIDATE THESE SERVICES. AND
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
SERVE VICTIMS. WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND PLAN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND I HOPE THAT
TODAY'S DISCUSSION WILL GET US
CLOSER TO ACHIEVING THEIR- THE
GOALS OF THE AGREEMENT MADE
ALMOST FOUR YEARS AGO. BEFORE I
BEGIN I WANT TO SHARE A STORY.
AND PART OF WHY WE'RE HAVING
THIS ITEM ON TODAY'S AGENDA. A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO I READ AN
ARTICLE ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE AND-
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
SUCK OUT IN THAT ARTICLE TO ME
BUT THERE WERE THERE WAS TO
MOTHERS. WHO WERE IN THAT
ARTICLE AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
HOW THEY SINCE HER SHOP WHEN I
WAS PARALYZED IN THE OTHER WAS
LEFT WITH SERIOUS INJURIES. WHAT
MOTHERS ARE FORCED TO ORGANIZE
THE GOAL FIND ME CAMPAIGN TO
HELP GET THEIR MED- HELP WITH
THEIR KIDS MEDICAL EXPENSES.
WE'VE ALL EARD ABOUT OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVING TO
ORGANIZE SIMILAR CAMPAIGNS FOR
FUNERAL COSTS BECAUSE THEY LOST
THEIR LOVED ONES. I DON'T KNOW
ALL THAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH-
AND I DO WONDER IF THEY WERE
AWARE OF THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM OR THE
REASONS WHY THEY'RE QUALIFIED
BUT MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE. OR
OF THE RESEARCHERS WERE NOT
ENOUGH- BUT IT'S CLEAR TO ME
THAT PARTICIPATING JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES. IF YOU TRY TO
MAKE THE MUSCLE AS POSSIBLE AND
HAVING TO RESORT TO A GO FUND ME
CAMPAIGN- IS NOT WHERE WE WANT
CALIFORNIA TO BE. AND SO. I DO
THINK EVERYONE HAS DURING THIS
FOR TODAY'S DISCUSSION AND I
LOOK FORWARD. TO THE WORK- WITH
MY COLLEAGUES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HOPEFULLY.
CREATE A BETTER PROGRAM- AND
HAVE THAT KIND OF CONSOLIDATION
WHICH- ALL FOR THE BETTER
PROGRAM AS WELL. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE ONE MORE NOTE- THE
PANELISTS ARE LISTED IN OR A
SPEAKING ORDER BUT I DO HAVE ONE
PANELIST DR GINA CASTRO
RODRIGUEZ THAT WILL NEED TO
LEAVE AT THE THIRTY. WE WILL
HEAR FROM ALL OF OUR PANELISTS.
AND THEN RETURNED TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. UNTIL WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST PANELIST. WE HAVE A
SPEAKERS READING. WE CAN DO WE
HAVE LINDA GLEDHILL EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR CAL VCB READY TO
SPEAK. WHEN THEY'RE WALKING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. LINDA HOLD ON WE
STILL CAN'T HEAR YOU. ARE YOU
MEET AT BY ANY CHANCE ON YOUR
END. NO WE CAN'T HEAR YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
HERE IN THE ROOM. THE. THEN THEY
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- EVERY DAY IS AN
ADVENTURE IN THIS ONLINE WORLD
SO. YEAH THANK YOU CHAIRED A
SIERRA AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING TODAY MY NAME IS
LINDA BLOOD ON THE DOCKING OF
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE
DO ACTUALLY SEE B. AND TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
. I STARTED IT COUNTIES TO BE
JUST OVER TWO YEARS AGO. PRIOR
TO THIS POSITION I WAS AT THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. I
ALSO HAVE WORKED IN THE STATE
SENATE AND I WAS A REPORTER FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE.
SINCE COMING OUT OF THE C. B. I
HAVE FOCUSED ON IMPROVING OUR
OPERATIONS BOTH INTERNALLY AND
EXTERNALLY. WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE VICTIMS BETTER AND SO
INTERNALLY I FOCUSED ON BUILDING
A STRONG MANAGEMENT TEAM AS WELL
AS ENSURING THAT OUR CHECK THAT
TECHNICAL SECURITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS UP TO DATE.
AND EXTERNALLY I REALLY ASSESS
THE NEEDS OF VICTIMS AND HOW WE
MAY BETTER SERVE THEM. AND I'M
PROUD OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE
HAVE MADE INCLUDING A SHARP
DECREASE IN APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIME BUT NO THERE
REMAINS MUCH MORE TO DO. I'VE
ALSO WORKED ON IMPLEMENTING CHIU
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ONE OF WHICH COMPENSATES VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING FOR INCOME
LOSS. AND THE OTHER WHICH PAYS
VICTIMS OF STATE SPONSORED
STERILIZATION. I'LL TALK MORE
ABOUT BOTH OF THESE A LITTLE
LATER. TO BEGIN I'D LIKE TO TELL
YOU ABOUT THE HISTORY AND
PURPOSE OF TRAVESTY BE. HAVING
TO BE WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE AND IT WAS THE FIRST
PROGRAM OF ITS KIND IN THE
NATION. IN MY TIME HERE AT. B.
C. B. I'VE LEARNED FIRSTHAND THE
VITAL WORK THAT WE DO TO ASSIST
THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS OF CRIME
EACH YEAR. HELPING THEM RECOVER
FROM TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES. IT
IS AN HONOR TO HAVE THIS
POSITION AND I TAKE SERIOUSLY MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
HELP THOSE WHO NEED OUR SUPPORT
. OUR TASK IS DIFFERENT SERVE
THOSE WHO ARE MIGHT BE HURT BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE.
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ASSAULT.
HOMICIDE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ROBBERY. VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER
AMONG OTHER CRIMES. VICTIMS WHO
SUFFERED PHYSICAL INJURY THREAT
OF PHYSICAL INJURY OR EMOTIONAL
INJURY AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THESE CRIMES MAY QUALIFY FOR
ASSISTANCE THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
MAY ALSO QUALIFY. TELEVISI BT
PROVIDES UP TO SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENT OF
EXPENSES AS A PAIR OF LAST
RESORT. TO COVER COSTS CREATED
BY THE FRONT. THESE INCLUDE
MEDICAL AND DENTAL CARE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCOME LOSS
FUNERAL EXPENSES RELOCATION
COSTS AND RESIDENTIAL SECURITY.
THERE OF LAST RESORT MEANS THE
COMPANY SHOULD BE CAN ONLY PET
FENCES AFTER OTHER AVAILABLE
SOURCES A PAYMENT HAVE BEEN
APPLIED TO A BILL. THE SOURCES
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
HEALTH INSURANCE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE
AUTOMOBILE INSURANCE MEDICARE
AND MEDICARE. THE BENEFITS WOULD
PROVIDE AND REQUIREMENTS FOR
RECEIVING THEM OF COURSE THAT
OUT AND STATURE. STATUTORY
LIMITATIONS ARE IN PLACE FOR
SEVERAL CATEGORIES. RELOCATION
FUNERAL BURIAL EXPENSES AND
CRIME SCENE CLEANUP ARE THERE IS
MOST UNDER FUNDED BASED ON
STATISTICS AND FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY. THE MAXIMUM BENEFITS
IN THESE ERRORS WERE SET BY
STATUTE IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
AND THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED SINCE
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE REQUESTING
INCREASES THIS YEAR.
ORGANIZATION LAID COVEY C. B.
FALLS UNDER THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. WE'RE
GOVERNED BY A THREE MEMBER BOARD
THAT MEETS ONCE EVERY TWO
MONTHS. THE BOARD IS CHAIRED BY
THE SECRETARY BELLHOPS AND ALSO
INCLUDES THE CONTROLLER AND A
NUMBER APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THAT NUMBER IS
CURRENTLY CONTRA COSTA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DIANA PATRONS. LAST
FISCAL YEAR COPIES TO BE
RECEIVED MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS AND PAID
FIFTY TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN COMPENSATION TO
VICTIMS. THE TOP THREE TYPES OF
CRIME RECEIVED APPLICATIONS FOR
WORK ASSAULT. CHILD ABUSE AND
HOMICIDE. AND THE TOP TOP THREE
EXPENSES THAT WE COVERED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FUNERAL BURIAL AND
INCOME LOSS OF WORK. THESE ARE
SERIOUS CRIMES WAS SERIOUS
IMPACTS IN THE STAFFORDSHIRE BCB
ARE DEDICATED TO HELPING EVERY
PERSON WE POSSIBLY CAN. WE KNOW
THE IMPACT OF CRIME CAN BE FAR
REACHING AND LONG LASTING AND WE
DO ALL WE CAN WITHIN OUR
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK TO PROVIDE
THE HELP THAT THE VICTIMS NEED.
THEIR DIVISIONAL STATISTICS
ABOUT OUR PROGRAM IN YOUR AGENDA
PAPERS AND WE PUBLISH AN ANNUAL
REPORT. SUMMARIZING ART
ACTIVITIES ENERGY DATA FROM THE
PREVIOUS FISCAL YEAR. I PROVIDED
COPIES TO THE TWENTY AND THAT
REPORT IS AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC ON OUR WEBSITE. IN
ADDITION TO THE CORE MISSION OF
COMPENSATING VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIME HEALTH NEEDS TO BE RUN
SEVERAL OTHER PROGRAMS TO HELP
VICTIMS. WOULD COMPENSATE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED OF A CRIME AND SPENT
TIME IN PRISON. IT'S CASES ARE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS PENAL
CODE SECTION FORTY NINE HUNDRED
CASES. CURRENTLY ONE CALL THE C.
B. APPROVES A CLAIM IT GOES TO
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE THE CLAIM
TO BE PAID. ALSO CAN TAKE MANY
MONTHS BETWEEN THE TIME THE
CLAIM IS APPROVED BY THE BOARD
THE BILL PASSES THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE PAYMENTS MADE TO THE
VICTIM. IN AN EFFORT TO EXPEDITE
THIS PROCESS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES APPROPRIATING
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND CHAO B. C. B. AND
THAT WE ALONG WITH THE
CORRESPONDING STATUTORY CHANGES
WOULD ALLOW COPIES TO BE TO PAY
THE CLAIM DIRECTLY. B. C. B.
ALSO PROVIDES GRANTS TO CROMER
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS BETTER
KNOWN AS TRC'S ACROSS THE STATE
TO HELP VICTIMS OF CRIME. SHARE
SEIZE PROVIDE TRAUMA INFORMED
EVIDENCE BASED MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES TO CRIME VICTIMS WHO
MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR VETERANS
COMPENSATION OR MAYBE FAIR OF
REPORTING CRIMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HAVE A SEAT
CURRENTLY FUNDS EIGHTEEN TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS THROUGH GRANT
AGREEMENTS WITH THEM SURE THAT
THEY MEET STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
. YOUR SIS MUST FOR EXAMPLE USE
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY TREATMENT
TEAM SIR VICTIMS OF ALL TYPES OF
VIOLENT CRIME AND TREAT CLIENTS
WITH COMPLEX PROBLEMS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR EMOTIONAL OR BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES. WCB ALSO SUPPORTS
VICTIMS OF MASS VIOLENCE EVENTS
SUCH AS THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING
THE GOVERNOR LET FESTIVAL AND
MOST RECENTLY THE SAN JOSE VGA
SHOOTING THAT OCCURRED LAST MET
. IN ALL CASES OUR GOAL IS TO
HELP VICTIMS BEGIN TO RECOVER
FROM THE TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE
ENTERED AND HELP THEM MOVE ON
WITH THEIR LIVES. IN ADDITION TO
DIRECT VICTIMS OF CRIME WE COVER
WHAT WE CALL DERIVATIVE VICTIMS.
DRIVEN THE VICTIMS OR SURVIVORS
OF CRIME VICTIMS WHO HAVE DIED.
PERSONS ARE LEGALLY DEPENDENT
UPON THE VICTIM FOR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND MEMBERS OF THE
VICTIMS FAMILIES THIS CAN
INCLUDE PARENTS GRANDPARENTS
SIBLINGS SPOUSES CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN. TELL ME CITY IS
FUNDED THROUGH RESTITUTION FINES
AND PENALTY ASSESSMENTS LET ME
KNOW FIRST AND CONVICTED OF
CRIMES AND TRAFFIC OFFENSES AND
RESTITUTION ORDERS. OBVIOUSLY
THESE MAIN FUNDING SOURCES OF
THE RESTITUTION FUND AND FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS. THE FEDERAL
VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT KNOWN AS
VOTER REIMBURSES WRITTEN THE
RESTITUTION FUND 475% THE VICTIM
CLAIM PAYMENTS MADE FOR STATE
FUNDS. THIS IS AN INCREASE FROM
60% TO CHANGE NOT TO ONE
PRESIDENT FINDS AND THE VOTER
FITS THAT IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AS SUCH WE ARE
REQUESTING AN INCREASE DROP
FEDERAL PREPARATION THIRTY TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS CHANGE ENABLE
US TO PASS THE REIMBURSEMENT
ONTO THE RESTITUTION FUND. IT IS
A KEY SOURCE REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THE RESTITUTION FUND WAS RE
DIRECTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
COUNTY CITY HAS NEEDED
INCREASING SUPPORT FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. TREMAIN SOLVENT
ENABLE US TO CONTINUE TO HELP
VICTIMS. THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
PROVIDES THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR RESTITUTION FUND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THE RESTITUTION ON. AS
I MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING ONE
THING I'VE WORKED HARD TO DO A
TRAVESTY IS IMPROVE OUR
EFFICIENCY AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
WORKLOAD TRACTOR WE WERE ABLE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT PROCESSES
WERE SLOWING US DOWN AND CREATE
NEW PROCESSES TO MOVE
APPLICATIONS MORE EFFECTIVELY.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT WE NOW
PROCESS APPLICATIONS 40% FASTER
THAN WE DID TWO YEARS AGO. THE
AVERAGE APPLICATION CURRENTLY
TAKES US THIRTY TWO DAYS TO
PROCESS WE STRIVE EVERY DAY TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THAT NUMBER
. WE KNOW THAT EVERY DAY AN
APPLICANT WAITS TO HEAR FROM US
IS A DATE THAT THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO GET THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED TO RECOVER FROM THE CRIME
THAT THEY EXPERIENCED. ANOTHER
IMPORTANT FOCUS FOR ME WAS TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR VETERANS TO
UNDERSTAND OUR PROGRAM AND
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION. WE
OVERHAULED OUR WEBSITE LAST
SPRING TO MAKE IT SIMPLE EASY TO
USE AND VICTIM CENTER. WE DID
THIS BY CLEARLY LAYING OUT
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. THE WEBSITE
ALSO HAS THE LOOK AND FEEL THAT
IS PURPOSELY DESIGNED NOT TO
LOOK LIKE A GOVERNMENT WEBSITE
AND IT INCLUDES A QUICK ESCAPE
AND TO HELP VICTIMS. CALIFORNIA
HAS A PROUD HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING VICTIMS AND OVER THE
YEARS PROBABLY SEE THESE
MEASUREMENTS BROWN. UNDER
LEGISLATION ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING- ENTITLED UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR TWO YEARS FOR INCOME LOST.
UNDER THIS LAW SO FAR WE HAVE
PAID TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY VICTIMS. AND THIS
PAST SUMMER THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THE FORCED OR
INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM TO PAY
VICTIMS OF STATE SPONSORED FOR
STERILIZATION. WE LAUNCH THAT
PROGRAM ON JULY FIRST I'M SORRY
JANUARY FIRST AND THE VICTIMS
HAVE UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO APPLY.
THERE IS FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN REPARATIONS TO
SPLIT EVENLY AMONG ALL ELIGIBLE
CLAIMANTS TO APPLY. CAMPISI BE
CONTINUES TO WORK TO EXPAND ITS
NOT WORKING BY WITH MEETING WITH
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
VICTIM SERVICE PROVIDERS
ADVOCATES COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
COURT OFFICIALS AS WELL AS OUR
STATE COLLEGE. WE REESTABLISHED
A VICTIM ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE A FORUM FOR VICTIM
SERVICE TAKE ORDERS TO ADDRESS
COMMON PROBLEMS SUCH AS HOW TO
OVERCOME OBSTACLES CREATED BY
THE CAN DOWN. AND WHILE THEY'RE
ON THE ADVISER TOO MANY PROBABLY
TO BE ALSO MEET SEPARATELY WITH
GROUPS SUCH AS CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND THE AND
THAT'S THE- INNOCENCE PROJECT.
TO HEAR THEIR CONCERNS FOR
DISTRUST LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
WELL ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE NOW
ESTABLISHED A VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAM
CALIFORNIANS IS THE MOST ROBUST
IN TERMS OF THE SERVICE WE
PROVIDE TO VICTIMS AND THE MOST
COMPLEX IN TERMS OF OUR
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. WE ARE
FOCUSED ON HELPING VICTIMS OF
CRIME RECOVERED FROM THE PAIN
AND INJURIES CAUSED BY VIOLENT
CRIME. OR IN THE CASE OF THOSE
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED OR SUBJECT
TO GOOD FOR STERILIZATION OF A
GRAVE INJUSTICE. I TRAVESTY BE
WE ARE DRIVEN BY THIS IMPORTANT
AND MEANINGFUL MISSION THAT EACH
YEAR HELPS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OVERCOME DRAMATIC
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I THINK
IT'S A THIRTY MINUTE WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF FOR OUR
PANELISTS. DO WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE- NEXT. READ
AND SHARE MEMBERS CHOOSE SORT OF
MORE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I WILL BE FILLING IN FOR
JESSICA PETERS TODAY- I WAS
NOTED EARLIER IN THEIR HEARING
AS PART OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN
OF TWENTY BUDGET AGREEMENT THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE AGREED
IN CONCEPT TO CONSOLIDATE THE
VICTIM SERVICE PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY OPERATED BY CAL B. C.
B. AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. INTO A NEW
VICTIM SERVICES DEPARTMENT UNDER
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
. THE PLAN TO- CARRY OUT THE
CONSOLIDATION WAS DEFERRED UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN ORDER TO
GIVE THE ADMINISTRATION TIME TO.
COME UP WITH A DETAILED PLAN
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY HOW TO CARRY
OUT THE CONSOLIDATION. HOWEVER
THE ADMINISTRATION DECLINED TO
SUBMIT A PROPOSAL AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET CITING
THE ONSET OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND THE RESULTING
WORKLOAD FOR- WE ASK AS BEING A
BARRIER TO DOING SO WE WOULD
NOTE HOWEVER THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DID SUBMIT AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET PACKAGE A PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE- YESS RESPONSIBILITIES.
BY CONSOLIDATING THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION UNDER ITS
PURVIEW. DEGREE NEED TO
CONSOLIDATE THE PROGRAM UNDER
THESE PROGRAMS UNDER NEW
DEPARTMENT WAS THE RESULT OF
MULTIPLE YEARS OF INTEREST FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AND MAKING A CHANGE. FOR
EXAMPLE A TWENTY FIFTEEN REPORT
FILED BY OUR OFFICE RECOMMENDED
CONSOLIDATING VICTIMS PROGRAMS
INTO A SINGLE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
WE IDENTIFIED VARIOUS WEAKNESSES
IN THE EXISTING SYSTEMS
SPECIFICALLY WE NOTED THAT THERE
IS A LACK OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN- YES THE BECOMES
COMPENSATION BOARD. THAT THE
STATE COULD BE MISSING OUT ON
OPPORTUNITIES TO DRAW DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS. AND
THAT UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM IN
WHICH THERE'S NUMEROUS DUPLICATE
OF SMALL GRANTS THAT ARE
NARROWLY TARGETED. IT REDUCES
THE EFFICIENCY AND POTENTIAL
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
OVERALL ATTEMPT TO SUPPORT
VICTIMS PROGRAMS. THESE CONCERNS
THAT WE BROUGHT UP IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN GENERALLY CONTINUE TO
APPLY GIVEN THESE CONCERNS AND
THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
OF THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
ASK THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
WHAT ITS PLANS ARE TO COME
FORWARD WITH A DETAILED PROPOSAL
TO CONSOLIDATE THE VICTIMS
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY OPERATED BY-
YES. AND THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD INTO A NEW
CONSOLIDATED. DEPARTMENT THANK
YOU. THANK OU NEXT WE HAVE.
TINASHE HOLLAND'S CALIFORNIA AND
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
AFTERNOON CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS TO MEET TOLERANCE I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE I'M ALSO THE FORMER
STATE DIRECTOR OF CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
WHICH IS OUR NETWORK OF CRIME
SURVIVORS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WELL THE LARGEST MEMBERSHIP WITH
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
pTHROUGHOUT THE STATE. I'M REALLY
HONORED TO BE HERE I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THIS CONVERSATION I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND CAL B. C. B. S.
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTOR CLINT HILL
FOR ALL THE WORK AND AS SUPPORT
SHE'S OFFERED TO CRIME VICTIMS
AND THEIR OFFICES OFTENTIMES
THEY CAN THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH DOCTOR
BACILLARY- IN UNICAST RODRIGUEZ
AND OTHER FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING
VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE THE
ISSUES. OF THE CONTENTS. OF
IRIZARRY DRESSED HERE IN THE
STATE- THERE COUPLE THINGS I WON
OFFERINGS. OF THE PERSPECTIVE
AROUND CHALLENGES FOR VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE ALREADY BEEN NOTED BY
DIRECTOR CLAY HILL AND I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHERS- AROUND
THE CHANGES THAT ARE WORKING TO
BE MADE- IN DESPITE. ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS IT IS THAT THERE'S A
VERY REAL WHO NEED FOR US TO
CONTINUE PRIORITIZING. VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS AND REMOVE-
CHALLENGES TO GETTING ACCESS TO
THE SUPPORT THAT WE ALL NEED AND
DESERVE. I HAVE A CRIME
SURVIVORS SOME OF WHOSE BEEN
INTEGRATED DRIVEN IT BIG TIME-
BY LOSING TO AND THERE'S A NON
VIOLENCE IN MY HOME TOWN OF SAN
FRANCISCO. AND UNFORTUNATELY
EXPERIENCING OTHER VICTIM
EXPERIENCES I KNOW FIRST HAND-
THE BARRIERS THAT WE HAVE FACED.
AND THE COUNTERS THAT WE HAVE TO
ACCESSING IMMEDIATE SUPPORT. OF
WIND THERE IS A THAT INCIDENT
THAT AFFECTS. US ALL IN OUR
FAMILIES. DESPITE THESE.
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT BEEN DIRECTED. TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SPENDING OVER
THE PAST THREE DECADES. THE
MAJORITY OF SURVIVORS THAT ARE
ST STILL ARE STRUGGLING TO
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO. RECOVER FROM HARM. IN
THE STATE SPENDING ON DEFENSE
SERVICES. REPRESENTS ABOUT 1% OF
WHAT THE STATE SPENDS ON THE
PRISON SYSTEM AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT. IN OTHER WORDS
CALIFORNIA SPENDS NEARLY EIGHTY
TIMES MORE. ON THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM CORPORATION IT DOES
FOR VICTIMS. OF CRIME. AND EVEN
WITH MILLION. RESIDENTS IMPACTED
BY VIOLENCE EVERY YEAR THE STATE
WE KNOW CAN DO MORE AND IS
WORKING TO DO MORE TO SCALE UP.
AN ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS THAT
EXIST IN TO INTEGRATE SURVIVOR
VOICES AND LEADERSHIP INTO
POLICY MAKING- ENERGY PRESSING
BARRIERS THAT MAKE IT HARD FOR
US TO GET THE SUPPORT IN FACT. A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY OF
CALIFORNIA CRIME SURVIVORS FOUND
THAT FEWER THAN ONE IN FIVE
VICTIMS ACTUALLY RECEIVED ANY
MEDICAL FINANCIAL OR MENTAL
HEALTH. SUPPORT ALONG WITH THE
OTHER HEALING SERVICES TO HELP
THEM RECOVER. DESPITE MAJORITY-
THAT ARE WAITING TO GET ACCESS
TO THE SERVICES. AND AGAIN ALL
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT ARE BECOME
COMPENSATION PROGRAM AND SAY IN
CALIFORNIA IS A- NATIONAL
LEADER- THE SURVIVAL OF THE
SURVIVORS THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION ARE STILL FACING
VERY SIGNIFICANT HURDLES. TO
ACCESSING IT THERE ARE STILL
THOUSANDS OF CLAIMS THAT ARE
DENIED EVERY YEAR AND IS A
RECENT ANALYSIS THAT FOUND THAT
THE TYPES OF COMPENSATION
ELIGIBILITY RESTRICTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS. INCLUDING
CONVICTION BASED RESTRICTIONS
DENIALS FOR ALLEGED LACK OF
COOPERATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESTRICTIONS BASED ON A
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTION TO THE
VICTIMIZATION. ARE INHERENTLY
AND SYSTEMICALLY RACIST AND THEY
pRELY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT OPINION
WHICH OF COURSE. BECAUSE OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATE I DIDN'T ALLEN
COMPENSATION FOR BACK FOR BLACK
VICTIMS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE
WAY DIFFICULT COM. PROGRAM IS
FUNDED IS ALSO NOT SUSTAINABLE
IN THE LONG TERM THE RESTITUTION
FROM THE PROVIDES THE MAJORITY
OF FUNDING FOR VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. HAS IN RECENT
YEARS IT MORE THAN IT IS TAKING
IN THE STATE HAS BACK FLLED
SOME OF THIS LOSS WITH GENERAL
FUNDS AND HAS NOT- RETHOUGHT THE
OVERALL MODEL FOR AND- WE DO
APPLY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING AN
ONGOING THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION TO THE RESTITUTION
FINE WE KNOW THE CALIFORNIA MUST
COMMIT FULLY TO FUNNY THE
COMPENSATION PROGRAM IN GENERAL
FUND DOLLRS AND THIS FINE
CURRENTLY RELIES ON REVENUE.
FROM CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS FINES
AND FEES IT'S INHERENTLY
UNSTABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
OWNERS FINDING FEES ALSO TRACK
PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICES. AND
CYCLES OF IMPOSSIBLE DEBT
FRUSTRATE INABILITY TO MOVE PAST
THE CONVICTION DOES VERY LITTLE
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY IT ACTUALLY
PUTS SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS IT
MORE HARD. CONTINUE TO RELY THE
SYSTEM IS COUNTER TO
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES AND I KNOW
IT'S ALSO COUNTER TO WHAT. MANY
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY- ARE ALIGNED WITH IN
WANT TO SEE MORE HAPPEN TO KEEP
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS STATE AT
SAFE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
. SO IT IS TIME FOR A NEW
APPROACH THAT REALLY REQUIRES US
TO EXPAND VICTIM SERVICES
ELIGIBILITY TO ALL VICTIMS OF
CRIME. AN ALL CRIME EXPERIENCES.
THE EXCLUSION. THAT WE HAVE TO
ACCESS VICTIM SERVICES. SHUT OUT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED I'M PROVIDE BY VIOLENT
CRIME IN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AGAINST BLACK VICTIMS AND
VICTIMS FROM COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SEVERELY IMPACTED BY CRIME.
WHILE THESE WHILE THERE ARE
BENEFITS- IN PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS. SUCH AS VICTIMS
COMPENSATION VICTIM SERVICES AND
SOME PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE
BIXEL. OUR JOB LOSSES THAT ARISE
FROM VICTIMIZATION THOSE
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS ARE
STILL NOT READILY AVAILABLE TO
ALL VICTIMS OF CRIME. CALIFORNIA
HAS TO IN THE DISCRIMINATOR
DISCRIMINATORY. RULES AND
PRACTICES THAT TREAT VICTIMS
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON THEIR
DEPENDING STATUS OR
DEMOGRAPHICS. AND EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY TO SERVICES AND
COMPENSATION TO ALL VICTIMS
EXPLICITLY AFFIRMING PROTECTIONS
TO ALL VICTIMS IS CRUCIAL TO
HEALING. INTO STOPPING THE CYCLE
OF VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS INCLUDES ANY
EXCLUSIONS THAT BLAME VICTIMS
FOR THEIR OWN VICTIMIZATION.
PREVENT ELIGIBILITY- IN
EXTENDING ELIGIBILITY BENEFITS
AND PROTECTIONS TO FOLKS WHO
WITNESS VIOLENCE. DRIVEN IF
FAMILY MEMBERS. OF A VIOLENT
CRIME. IN PEOPLE WITH PRIOR
RECORDS- MAY. BE IN A PROBATION
OR PAROLE- IN VICTIMS POLICE. I
ELIGIBILITY ALSO NOT PLEASE
REFER OF WHEN TYPE OF
DOCUMENTATION AVAILABLE AND SO
WE WANT TO MOVE TOWARD OF THE
NEW CHANGES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT. IN DISPENSARY
IS. AND REDUCE BIGGEST DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION WANT TO STABILIZE
FUNDING WE WANT TO PROVIDE A
LOCAL ARTIST FLEXIBLE CASH
ASSISTANCE IN VERY QUICKLY TO
SURVIVORS IN THIS IS A CRITICAL
PART OF THE SAFETY THAT OUR
DOLLARS ARE NOT ONLY READILY
ACCESSIBLE BUT THAT THEY ARE
FLEXIBLE. IT IS AN INDEPENDENT-
EXPERIENCE FOR VICTIMS TO BE
HARMED AND EACH INDIVIDUAL HAS
VERY SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
DOESN'T OFTEN SUPPORT OF THE
OPPORTUNITY. KIND OF THEY NEED
IN THE MOMENT WHEN THEY REALLY
FLEXIBILITY CASH ASSISTANCE TO
SURVIVORS IS A CRITICAL PART. OF
MAKING SURE THAT OUR STATE AND
OUR SURVIVORS WHO WITH THE NEED-
THAT INCLUDES DIRECT CASH
ASSISTANCE. AND MADE READILY
AVAILABLE THROUGH TRUSTED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE
DON'T WANT SURVIVORS TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE- THE
PROMISES THAT THE ADDITIONAL
TRAUMA- IN SYSTEMIC BARRIERS OF
HAVING TO GO THROUGH A LOCAL
AGENCIES WHEN THEY CAN GET
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES DIRECTLY FROM PEOPLE
THAT THEY HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH IN THEIR COMMUNITY. WERE
ABLE TO SHOW UP AND CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THEM AS THEY MAKE
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE HEALING
PROCESS AND RECOVER IN THEIR
LIVES AND SO WE'RE REALLY
CALLING FOR. THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF A STATE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
GRANTS TO TRUST A COMMUNITY
BASED IN SURVIVOR LED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ROOTED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AUTHORIZING
THESE GRANTEES TO SUB GRANT AND
DIRECTLY- PROVIDE CASH THE CASH
SUPPORT TO VICTIMS. TRAUMATIZE
AN ENDANGERED WITNESSES AND
THEIR LOVED ONES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROGRAM ALSO
LIMITS ANY BURDENSOME PAPERWORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT- URGENTLY THE
RESOURCES CAN BE MOVED TO
SURVIVORS WITH VERY MINIMAL RED
TAPE. WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND AND BUILD ON THE TRUMP
RECOVERY SANTA MONICA SINGER
MODEL- STATEWIDE. SINCE THAT WE
MENTIONED BEFORE- OF. THE
CHALLENGES- DID THE BARRIERS TO
SAFETY THEY OFTENTIMES THIS
PROVIDES OR CREATES FOR
SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY BLOCK LIKE
BECOMES AND SURVIVORS AND FOLKS
WHAT IMPACT THE COMMNITY ONE
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL JURY POSITION
TO CREATE COMMUNITY BASED
CULTURALLY COMPETENT TRUMP'S
AMERICA EVERY CENTERS FOR
MARGINALIZED VICTIMS I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
HOUSING ADJUSTABILITY AND ENSURE
LEGAL PROTECTION SO THAT ARE
SPIDERS DO NOT CONTINUE TO
ENDANGER THEMSELVES BY LOSING.
THEIR STABILITY FOR THE SAKE OF
MOVING TOWARDS SAFETY SUBJECT
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME- TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK ON THE PRIORITIES
THAT WE ALL AS SURVIVORS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. LIKE TO SEE THE
STATE PRIORITIZE. THANK YOU MISS
HOLLAND'S NEXT WE HAVE DOCTOR
GINA CASTRO RODRIGUEZ. ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. THANK YOU A CHAIR
GARCIA AND THANK YOU TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. I AM
AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
THE GRADUATE COUNSELING
PSYCHOLOGY DEPARTMENT BUT I ALSO
HAVE THIRTY YEARS OF WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY ON VICTIM AND SURVIVOR
ISSUES MOST RECENTLY I WAS THE
CHIEF OF THE SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR SEVEN YEARS BEFORE
LEAVING- LAST SPRING. I COME
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE AND THE NEED
FOR SUPPORT IN HEALING AND
RECOVERY- APPRECIATE THE- REPORT
BY- SQUAD HILL AND- ALL THE WORK
THAT CAL BCB HAS DONE. TO
IMPROVE- TIMES YOU KNOW THAT THE
TIME IT TAKES TO PROCESS AN
APPLICATION AND IMPROVING THE
RATE OF DENIALS- BUT WE STILL A
LOT OF WORK TO DO TO HELP
SURVIVORS HEAL AND RECOVER. FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS I'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF RESEARCH WITH
SURVIVORS OF CRIME AND HEARING
DIRECTLY FROM THEM ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES. ENGAGING THEM WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND ACCESSING
RESOURCES TO HEALING AND
RECOVERY WE'VE A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING. OUT IN THE FIELD WITH
SURVIVORS AND HOW THEY'RE
ENGAGING WITH THE SYSTEMS WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND
WHAT THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
AND I'LL SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE
TODAY. THE FIRST MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT WE FOCUS ON
HEALING AND RECOVERY. WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL AND RECOVER
FROM TRAUMA FROM VIOLENCE FROM
CRIME THERE ARE MORE AT RISK FOR
ADDITIONAL VICTIMIZATION BEING A
CRIME VICTIM IN OTHER CASES.
THERE ARE MORE AT RISK FOR
COMMITTING VIOLENT ACTS
THEMSELVES. AND THEY REALLY
DON'T RECOVER FROM THE INCIDENT
AND INSTEAD THEY ARE BURIED
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES THAT PREVENT
THEM FROM FULLY ENGAGING AGAIN
IN RELATIONSHIPS. IN SOCIETY AND
IN MOVING FORWARD WITH THEIR
LIVES SO IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
- THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE WITH CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. DOESN'T MEET THE
NEEDS OF A LOT OF SURVIVORS SO
WE KNOW THAT WITH ALL OF THE
APPLICATIONS OF THE AND THE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN PAID OUT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE'RE STILL OVER ONLY AVERAGING
A LITTLE OVER A THOUSAND DOLLARS
A PERSON. ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE. DOLLARS AVERAGE.
THAT ALL OF THE FUNDING REALLY
DOESN'T START TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE NEEDS OF VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS IN THEIR RECOVERY
AFTER CRIME VICTIMIZATION WE
ALSO KNOW THAT LESS THAN 1% OF
THE SURVIVORS APPLY FOR
COMPENSATION EVER COME CLOSE TO
THE SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR MAX-
THAT NUMBER IS OFTEN USED TO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO EXPAND
SERVICES INVICTA POP STATION
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT A REALISTIC
NUMBER TO MEASURE. CHANGE
AGAINST. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES IS RAISING THE CAPS ON
THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES IN
WHICH CRIME SURVIVORS CAN APPLY
FOR WE COMPLETELY SUPPORT- IS
QUITE HELD IN THE- THE PROPOSED
RAISE ENOUGH CAPS PARTICULARLY
FOR THINGS LIKE WE LOCATION.
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN A
CRIME SURVIVOR IS NOT SAFE IN
THEIR OWN HOME ANYMORE AND THEY
NEED TO MOVE AND THE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP DOESN'T GO
VERY FAR IN CALIFORNIA. WE
SUPPORT THAT OUR RECOMMENDATION
AND ALSO FOR FUNERAL BURIAL THE
AMOUNT OF SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
INCREASED INFLATION AROUND
FUNERAL AND BURIAL AND IT DOES.
LEAVE MANY SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS
TO HAVE TO RAISE MONEY ON THEIR
OWN TO BURY THEIR LOVED ONE
WHILE THEY'RE STILL IN THE
AFTERMATH OF TRAUMA AND GRIEF
AND LOSS SO WE SUPPORT THOSE
THINGS. WE DO THINK THOUGH THAT
THERE SHOULD BE MORE OF THE THAT
WE SHOULD THINK MORE BROADLY
ABOUT WHO ARE SURVIVORS AND
VICTIMS OF CRIME. THERE ARE SO
MANY SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE AND
GUN VIOLENCE IN INTERPERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS THEY DON'T QUALIFY
FOR VICTIMS COMPENSATION- WE
NEED TO ALSO BROUGHT IN AS TO
NEEDS HOLLAND SAID. THE IDEA OF
WHO CAN RECEIVE COMPENSATION WE
HAVE MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE. MIRED
IN THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE THEY
HAVE BOTH EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE
AND COMMITTED VIOLENCE THEY LIVE
IN FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE VIOLENCE IS COMMON AND THE
REPLICATION OF THAT VIOLENCE IS
ACTUALLY HARMFUL TO THE
INDIVIDUAL IT'S HARMFUL TO THE
FAMILY. IT'S HARD FOR THE
COMMUNITY AT THE MELANIE IT'S
HARMFUL TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
YEAH I DIDN'T OUT IN SOCIETY AND
SO TREATING VIOLENCE IS A
FOUNDATIONAL MECHANISM FOR
ENDING VIOLENCE AND WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IT IN THAT WAY. AND
THE RESOURCES NEED TO BE
DIRECTED IN THAT WAY IN ORDER
FOR US. TO HAVE MORE SAFETY FOR
PEOPLE. I'M ONE OF THE STUDY'S
THAT I DIDN'T. YEAR WE ASK
SURVIVORS OUT HOW THEY FELT
ABOUT IN. BROADENING THE
DEFINITION OF VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS TO INCLUDE MORE PEOPLE
WHO HAD ACCESS TO RESOURCES-
THERE WAS A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
THIS IDEA INCLUDING SEVENTY
THREE PERCENT. IN 73% ENDORSED
SUPPORTING SURVIVORS OF POLICE
VIOLENCE AND 53% INDOOR
SUPPORTING SURVIVORS WHO HAD
HISTORIES OF PROBATION OR
PAROLE. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
WITH PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW ARE ARE
ENGAGED IN AFFECTED BY AND
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE SO THAT WE
PREVENT FUTURE VIOLENCE- ANOTHER
FINDING FROM THE STUDY IS THAT.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF REACH YOUR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM. IN THE
STUDY THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
CALLED SURVIVOR VOICES WHICH
WILL BE RELEASED SOMETIME AT THE
END OF THIS MONTH OR THE
BEGINNING OF MARCH 60% OF THOSE
POLLED SAID THAT THEY WERE NOT
OFFERED COMPENSATION. OF THE OF
THE PEOPLE WERE OFFERED
COMPENSATION THOUGH 89% OF THEM
APPLIED SO WHEN THEY KNOW ABOUT
THE PROGRAM THEY APPLY FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND OF THOSE 89% THAT
APPLIED 93% RECEIVED
COMPENSATION SO WE KNOW THAT THE
COMPENSATION IS VALUABLE IN THAT
IT HELPS PEOPLE BUT WE NEED THE
INFORMATION TO BE OUT THERE FOR
THEM. AND WE NEED PEOPLE TO KNOW
HOW THEY QUALIFY FOR IT AND WHAT
THEY CAN USE IT FOR-
UNFORTUNATELY 70% OF THOSE WHO
DID NOT GET. COMPENSATION NEVER
LEARNED WHY THEY DIDN'T GET
COMPENSATION. SO THEY'RE LEFT
BEING LET DOWN BY A SYSTEM THAT
THEY APPLY TO FOR SUPPORT AND
DIDN'T GET ANY A GOOD
INFORMATION OR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY THEY DIDN'T GET THAT
SUPPORT. AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT
FURTHER EXACERBATES THE TRAUMA
AND THE GRIEF AND THE LOSS THAT
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING WHEN OUR
SYSTEM LET THEM DOWN. SO WE NEED
BETTER COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
SURVIVORS ALSO. I'M THE LAST
THING TAT I WANT TO LAST THING
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS JUST
FROM THE SURVIVOR'S PERSPECTIVE
A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT THINGS-
SURVIVORS THEMSELVES HAVE RAISED
SOME REALLY BIG ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY THAT I JUST
LIKE TO ELABORATE ON THE FIRST
IS THE COOPERATION RISK
REQUIREMENT YOU KNOW COOPERATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR COMPENSATION IS
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR SOME
SURVIVORS IT'S DETERMINED AT THE
POINT OF THE POLICE REPORT SO
RIGHT IN THE MOMENT SURROUNDING
THE TRAUMA. YEAH IF THE
SURVIVORS EXPERIENCING A
DRAMATIC RESPONSE IF THEY ARE
FEARFUL IF THEY ARE HURT IF THEY
ARE GRIEVING IF THEY ARE IN
SHOCK THEN THEY MAY NOT
PARTICIPATE OR COOPERATE AND
THAT MAY BE PART OF THEIR
DRAMATIC REACTION NOT
NECESSARILY THEIR LACK OF
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT YET THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE VERY
QUICKLY IN THE PROCESS. THEY
SHOULD BE REMOVED AS A
QUALIFICATION FOR ACCESSING
COMPENSATION FOR SURVIVORS
THERE'S OTHER WAYS THAT W CAN
DO THIS- FOR EXAMPLE THEIR
INTERACTION WITH HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS THEIR INTERACTION WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS WITH
OTHER GOVERNMENT SERVICES WE CAN
USE OTHER MECHANISMS TO
DETERMINE IF SOMEONE IS
COMPLAINING OR TRYING TO REACH
RECEIVE SERVICS RATHER THAN THE
COOPERATION REQUIREMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ANOTHER DIFFICULT
ONE THAT SURVIVES EXPRESSES THE
REIMBURSEMENT ONLY MODEL THAT
THE SURVIVORS HAVE TO PAY FIRST
AND THEN WAIT TO BE REIMBURSED.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE CALL B. C.
B. HAS DECREASED THOSE
NOTIFICATION TIME SO THAT PEOPLE
KNOW- BETTER WHEN THEY ARE
EITHER FUNDED OR NOT FUNDED FOR
COMPENSATION BUT IT STILL
REQUIRES THEM TO PUT MONEY UP
FRONT. AND ONLY HAVE SURVIVORS
THAT ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK THEY CANNOT PAY UP
FRONT AND BE REIMBURSED SO THEY
OFTEN JUST DON'T APPLY FOR
SERVICES OR GET THINGS DONE LIKE
HAVING THE CLOCK CRIME SCENE
CLEANUP. OR MOVING TO BE SAFER
OR SEEKING TREATMENT AND CARE
AND SO THEY ARE NOT RECOVERING
BECAUSE OF THAT. CONTRIBUTION IS
ANOTHER BIG AREA- DECIDING IF
SOMEONE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
CRIME CAN OFTEN BE SUBJECTIVE
AND DETERMINED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND OFTEN LEAVES
REALLY DESERVING VICTIMS OUT. I
WAS IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
RECENTLY LISTENING TO SURVIVORS
SPEAKING LIVE LISTENING
SESSIONS. AND A SURVIVOR WHO-
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER HAD GOTTEN
INTO A CAR WITH SOMEONE WHO HAD
BEEN DRINKING. THAT DRUNK DRIVER
GOT INTO AN ACCIDENT SHE WAS
PARALYZED THE SURVIVOR WAS
PARALYZED BUT LIVED- AND SHE DID
NOT QUALIFY FOR COMPENSATION
BECAUSE SHE GOT INTO A CAR WITH
SOMEONE WHO HAD BEEN DRINKING.
AND SHE CERTAINLY DIDN'T GET
INTO A CAR WITH SOMEONE WHO'D
BEEN DRINKING THINKING THAT SHE
WOULD END UP PARALYZED AND
EVENTUALLY DYING FROM HER
INJURIES. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
OUR FAMILY GOT NO SUPPORT IN
MEDICAL BILLS AND FUNERAL BURIAL
OR ANY MAIL MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT FOR THEM. TO HEAL FROM
THIS TRAGIC LOSS. SO THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE WE HAVE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT HARM CAUSED BUT WE
ARE OUR RESOURCES DON'T CONNECT
FOR THAT KIND OF A SURVIVOR.
ANOTHER ISSUE I'D LIKE TO RAISE
AS A CLINICIAN IS THAT WE HAVE
VERY LOW FEES FOR THERAPISTS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS. AND
THAT IS A REAL BERIT BARRIER FOR
US ACCESSING MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDING PROPRIETORS AND
TREATMENT FOR SURVIVORS- THE
COMPENSATION RATE IS VERY LOW
LESS THAN A HUNDRED DOLLARS EVEN
FOR LICENSED CLINICIANS. WHICH
MEANS THAT MOST CLINICIANS WILL
NOT TAKE CRIED SURVIVORS ON
THEIR CASELOAD- IN THEIR PRIVATE
PRACTICE MAKING IT REALLY HARD
FOR US TO FIND TIMELY RESOURCES.
FOR OUR SURVIVORS INCLUDING
THINGS LIKE LANGUAGE CAPACITY OR
A SPECIALIZED TRAINING IN TRAUMA
OR CRISIS- IT'S VERY HARD FOR US
TO FIND PEOPLE THAT WILL WORK AT
THOSE LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATES
YET WE HAVE HUGE YOU NEED. BOTH
IN THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
FOR CRYING BIG UP BECOMES. I'M
THE LAST ONE IS THAT LOST WAGES
ARE OFTEN DEPENDENT ON
COOPERATION WITH AN EMPLOYER AND
WE HAVE HAD MANY SURVIVORS
DISCUSSED THEIR CHALLENGES WITH
GETTING THEIR EMPLOYERS TO
COOPERATE WITH US. AND THEREFORE
MISSING OUT ON SUPPORT. SO WE
KNOW THAT IF THISIS THE BARRIER
FOR MANY PEOPLE AND THEY WANT TO
APPLY FOR THE COMPENSATION AND
THEN THEY DON'T USE THAT TO HEAL
AND RECOVER AND TO GET BETTER
FOLLOWING THE CRIME
VICTIMIZATION. I'M IN A LOT I'M
SORRY THE LAST ONE IS SURVIVORS
OF GUN VIOLENCE WHO ARE OFTEN
NOT ELIGIBLE BECAUSE OF
CONTRIBUTION OR COOPERATION
ISSUES. IT'S REALLY IMPERATIVE
THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE HARMED NO
MATTER HOW THEY ARE HARMED
HEALING RECOVER IT PROTECTS THEM
IT PROTECTS THE FAMILY IT
PROTECTS THE REST OF US. WHO ARE
AROUND HIM BECAUSE IT DECREASES
VIOLENCE SO HEALING TRAUMA
DECREASES VIOLENCE. AND THE LAST
THING I WAS ASKED TO SPEAK
ABOUT- SOME GENDER RESPONSIVE-
ISSUES THAT ARE PARTICULAR
AROUND. VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND
WORKING WITH PRIME SURVIVORS-
COMPLEX TRAUMA WHICH IS TRAUMA
REACTIONS THAT MANY WOMEN AND
GIRLS EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY THE
TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO OR HAVE BEE TOWARD.
COMES FROM PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
IN RELATIONSHIPS WITH WHETHER
THOSE ARE FAMILY OR ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIPS- ARE A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE COMMUNITY
THE KIND OF HARM THAT'S CAUSED
FROM THAT KIND OF VIOLENCE. IS
REALLY CHALLENGING TO TREAT AND
IT TAKES- INTERVENTION AND
SUPPORT AND TREATMENT BUT IT'S
OFTEN NOT ACCESS BY PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE PROTECTING THE
PEOPLE OF HARM THEM. AND THEY
DON'T GET BETTER SO WE NEED WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT AND THEN
MAKE THE TREATMENT AND SERVICES
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THEM. WE ALSO
HAVE TO CONSIDER GENERATIONAL
TRAUMA- GENERATIONAL TRAUMA MAY
CAUSE PEOPLE TO NOT COOPERATE OR
TRUST OR DISCLOSED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY HAVE HAD.
IN THEIR FAMILY OR IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHY THOSE
CONTRIBUTION AND- COOPERATION.
EXCLUSIONS REALLY A FACT
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. ALSO ECONOMIC
ISSUES VICTIMS MAY BE MAY BE
DEPENDENT ON THE PERSON THAT
CAUSE THEM HARM THE PERSON
THAT'S CAUSING BY VIOLENCE. AND
IN THAT WAY THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
LEAVE OR TO DO ACCESS RESOURCES
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT LOSE THEIR
INCOME THEIR HOUSING. OTHER
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN THEY MIGHT
HAVE IMMIGRATION ISSUES THAT ARE
TIED TO THE PERSON THAT'S
CAUSING THEM HARM- AND THIS THIS
DOESN'T HELP THEM GET BETTER AND
RECOVER. AND HEAL FROM THE
TRAUMA SO WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WERE
REQUIRING VICTIMS TO DO IN ORDER
TO ACCESS SERVICES. AND THE LAST
THING I JUST WANT TO END WITH
THIS REALLY FOCUSING ON HEALING
AND RECOVERY. WHEN SOMEONE IS IN
A DRAMATIC RESPONSE.
PARTICULARLY IF THEY HAVE HAD
MULTIPLE THINGS HAPPEN TO THEM
IN THEIR LIFETIME. IT'S REALLY
HARD TO SEEK OUT AND COMPLY WITH
TREATMENT ESPECIALLY RIGHT AFTER
THE INCIDENT HAS HAPPENED. SO WE
NEED TO BETTER FOLLOW UP AND
COMMUNICATION AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TIMELINE OF
HOW PEOPLE REACT TO TRAUMA. AND
CREATE OUR SYSTEMS AROUND THAT
KNOWLEDGE NOT CREATE SYSTEMS
THAT PROVIDE BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE RESPONDING TO TRAUMA AND
VIOLENCE- AND NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS. SERVICES IMMEDIATELY BUT
MAY NEED THEM DOWN THE ROAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND
FOR THE IMPORT WORK YOU'RE DOING
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME NEXT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE DOCTOR ALICIA.
WHICH ARTILLERY DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL LINES THE TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DOCTOR ALICIA BACILLARY AND
I'M ON THE FACT. THAT THE A OF
THE IBC SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M
ALSO ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF THE
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER MODELED I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY. NOT TO HEAR
ME TALK ABOUT THE TRUMP BECAUSE
WE SENT A MODEL BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE OF SPIDERS
FACE AS THEY TRY TO ACCESS
SERVICES. TO BEGIN WITH YOU KNOW
THAT APPROXIMATELY 50% OF PEOPLE
WHO EXPERIENCE A VIOLENT CRIME.
END UP- EXPERIENCING SOME
PSYCHOLOGICAL DIFFICULTIES IF
THEY'RE NOT GIVEN TREATMENT IN A
TIMELY FASHION WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE DELAY IN TREATING TRAUMA.
ENDS UP HAVING A WHOLE HOST OF
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
ARE WE ARE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
DEVASTATING AFTERMATH THAT
DEPRESSION AND POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER. CAN HAVE ON A
VICTIM'S AND UNTREATED TRAUMA
ALSO LEADS TO- PEOPLE BEING
UNABLE TO WORK. LEADS TO
BANKRUPTCY PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO
MAINTAIN STABLE HOUSING LEADS TO
POOR QUALITY OF LIFE. AND ARE AS
WE'VE HEARD TODAY WE KNOW THAT
VIOLENCE NOT ONLY AFFECTS THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT IT HAS A RIPPLE
EFFECT. THROUGHOUT THEIR
FAMILIES AND INTO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE LIVE. AND
BOB WHAT ARE GOING TO BE SAYING
TODAY- IS REALLY ECHOING WHAT-
THE OTHER PANELISTS HAVE SAID
AND THAT IS FOR EXAMPLE- ONE
STUDY THAT WAS DONE. IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR OTHER STATES
I ENDED UP- IDENTIFIED ONLY 20%
OF THE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME
WHAT AWARE VICTIM COMPENSATION
FUNDS. ONLY 4% OF SURVIVORS OF
FELT THAT THEIR NEEDS WERE
ADDRESSED BY THE CURRENT VICTIM
SERVICE SYSTEM AND WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT THE MOST HAUNTED BY THE
LEAST HELPED AND WE KNOW THAT UP
COMMUNITIES FALL BELOW AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE
PARTICULARLY NOT GETTING THE
SERVICES THEY NEED THAT THEY ARE
FACING MANY MORE OBSTACLES AND
POPS UP MANY. MORE BATTERIES AND
OBSTACLES. SO TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES. ARE THE STATE. OF
ENDED UP CREATING A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE AND ASKED- THE
UC SAN FRANCISCO PARTNERING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA- VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAM TO DEVELOP
A DEMONSTRATION PROJECT CALLED
THE TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER AND
THE GOAL OF IT. WAS TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH AN ALTERNATIVE TO
TRADITIONAL VICTIM SERVICES ARE
WHICH IS BASED ON THE WEAK
REIMBURSEMENT RATE BASED ON THE
COMPENSATION FUND. AND SO THE
TERRACING MODEL WE HAVE
DEVELOPED THIS OVER A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME. AND THE THRUST
OF IT IS THE OTHER MODEL REALLY
I USED AS AN ASSERTIVE OUTREACH
MODEL SO WHAT WE DO WE MEET THE
CLIENT WHERE THEY ARE WE DO HOME
VISITS WE MEET PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY. WE PROVIDE PRACTICAL
ASSISTANCE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES WE KNOW THAT OUR
SURVIVORS NEED HELP WITH THE
WHOLE ARRAY OF THINGS THEY NEED
HELP. WITH GETTING SICK HOUSING
MAY NEED HELP IN FILING A POLICE
REPORT THEY NEED HELP IN
HEALING. SO WE ALSO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE BASED MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AS WELL. VERY
IMPORTANTLY THE TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTER THE ALSO HELPS TO
COORDINATE CARE. OVER THIS HUGE
SYSTEM THAT VICTIMS FIND
THEMSELVES TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEMS OF MEDICAL CARE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEGAL ISSUES AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. THIS
COORDINATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WITHOUT PROVIDING THIS
COORDINATION. WE KNOW WHAT
SURVIVORS EASILY CAN FOR THE
CRACKS AND EASILY CANNOT END UP
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. ALSO THE MODEL. I HAS BEEN
TO BE BOTH AND COST EFFECTIVE
OTHERS AROUND YOU STREET TRY
THAT WAS ON IT AND SUBSEQUENTLY
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
THAT THE MODEL IS BOTH
CLINICALLY AND COST EFFECTIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE WE WERE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE RATE BY
WHICH SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
RECEIVE ENTAL HEALTH FOLLOW UP
INCREASED FROM 6% TO SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT. WE WERE ABLE TO SHOW IT
INCREASING COOPERATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A 69% INCREASE
IN POLICE REPORTS FILED. BUT
VERY IMPORTANTLY. WE WERE ABLE
TO SHOW 74% IMPROVEMENT IN
MENTAL HEALTH AND- SIXTEEN
SESSIONS PTSD SYMPTOMS WERE
DECREASED BY FORTY SIX PERCENT.
AND SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION
DECREASED BY 47% AND IMPORT LEAD
TO USC WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
COST EFFECTIVE THAN USUAL CARE
THE T. R. C. MODEL COSTS. 34%
LESS THAN USUAL CAL. SO WITH THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES IN MIND THE
STATE LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED
INTO LAW SEVERAL INITIATIVES
THAT HAVE LEAD TO APPLICATION OF
CHEER SEASON CALIFORNIA. AND
BECAUSE OF THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT OF THIS MODEL AND
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD THEY ARE NOW EIGHTEEN TO
YOUR SEIZE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THIS HAS LED TO A REPLICATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO THERE ARE
NOW THIRTY NINETEEN OF CITIES
LOCATED IN EIGHT STATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
SUPPORT AND- HELP THE CITY FOR
THE SUPPORT AND BECAUSE OF THIS
THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS. AND
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIME I
NEVER RECEIVING SERVICES THROUGH
THE TNC MODEL OUT ABBA. FATHER
IS. YOUR SEATS ARE NOT LOCATE IN
EVERY COMMUNITY SO WE KNOW THAT
THESE VARIOUS STILL EXIST FOR A
LOT OF OUR- SURVIVORS AND EVEN
OF. VICTIMS ARE TREATED AT A TSC
STILL HAVING SOME PROBLEMS
ACCESSING- REIMBURSEMENT TO THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION FUND ALL WE
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THAT VICTIMS DO
NOT HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR
OUT OF POCKET. EXPENSES SUCH AS
BURIAL EXPENSES AND-THE
LOCATION OF COURSE. AND SO THEY
OFTEN HAVE TO WAIT YOU KNOW AT
LEAST A MONTH TO TWO MONTHS TO
HEAR WHETHER OR NOT THE
APPLICATION HAS BEEN APPROVED OR
DENIED. AND THEN IF IT'S BEEN
APPROVED THEY OFTEN HAVE TO WAIT
ANOTHER TWO MONTHS TO GET
REIMBURSED. FOR SERVICES AND HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN POINTED OUT MANY
OF OUR OTHER SURVIVORS SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR-
SERVICES UP FRONT- AND THERE'S
ALSO BEEN. OUT OF THE- THE BANK
. THAT KEEP WILL HAVE ALL A
POLICE. IS PROBLEMATIC MANY ARE
ARE AFRAID OF RETALIATION BY
PERPETRATORS OF MANY OF THEM-
MAY MISTRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
MANY OF THEM ARE SIMPLY SO
OVERWHELMED BY THE SYMPTOMS THAT
DRIVEN INTO ISOLATION.
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE BARRIERS
EXIST- I REALLY HAVE TO APPLAUD
CAL B. C. B. FOR ALL OF THE
CHANGES THEY'VE MADE OVER THE
YEARS THAT HAVE SIMPLIFIED
THINGS AND IN FACT. THEY'VE DONE
A GREAT JOB OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS TRANSLATING ANY OF THEIR
BROCHURES AND APPLICATIONS INTO
A LOT OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
HOWEVER MY SURVIVORS ARE STILL
TELLING US THAT SOME OF THE
CORRESPONDENCE THEY RECEIVED OF
AROUND APPROVAL OR DENIAL I
USUALLY JUST IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND I'M NOT TRANSLATED
INTO OTHER LANGUAGES- I HAVE
SEVERAL OTHER VIGNETTES BUT FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME- I THINK I WILL. AND NOW AND I JUST WANT TO.
MENTION THAT THE ISSUES THAT
WERE TODAY CAL. I'M NOT UNIQUE
TO. THE ARE ISSUES THAT. OF
VIOLENT CRIME ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE FACING- AND PARTICULARLY-
THE SYSTEM OF CARE IS BADLY
BROKEN IT'S IT IS NOT- THIS
BURDENSOME AND NOT PARTICULARLY
TIME TIME AWAY AND- I THINK
CALIFORNIA REALLY HAS TAKEN THE
LEAD IN THE COUNTRY. AROUND
VICTIM SERVICES AND- I BELIEVE
CONGRATULATE THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WANTING TO
ENVISION. RETHINKING THE WAY
SERVICES ARE DELIVERING
DELIVERED AT- THINKING ABOUT
CENTRALIZING VICTIM SERVICES SO
THAT THE SERVICES ARE DELIVERED
IN A EQUITABLE AND- HEALING WAY
FUMBLE MOMENT THIS FALL
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WE WILL WE
WILL OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
NOW OF THE PANELISTS- WE ALSO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CORRECT THAT- BEFORE I OPEN IT
UP TO MY COLLEAGUES- HERE I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE- PANELISTS WHO
ARE ALSO AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
BUT WANTED TO START OFF BY
ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHEN CAN
WE EXPECT TO SEE A VICTIM
SERVICE CONSOLIDATION PLAN WHERE
IN THE THIRTY YEAR OF A PANDEMIC
AND SO I DO UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
THINGS WERE DELAYED BUT WE WE'VE
LEARNED TO LIVE IN THIS NEW
REALITY- AND SO WOULD DO WE HAVE
A PLAN TO GET IS THAT
CONSOLIDATION PLAN ANYTIME SOON
. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS LINDA GLADSTONE I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION- AS YOU
HAD MENTIONED YOU KNOW SINCE
THIS WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. BUDGET
PROPOSAL MANY THINGS HAVE
CHANGED- AND IN THINKING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING STEPS TO FULLY ANALYZE
THAT. PULLING TOGETHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE THAT
SERVE VICTIMS OF CRIME TO TALK
THROUGH HOW THEY SERVE VICTIMS
AND WHETHER THERE IS AN OVERLAP
GAP OR NEED FOR CONSOLIDATION.
GIVEN THAT THE STATE WE'VE HAD
SO MUCH OF OUR VOTERS
APPROPRIATELY DIRECTED TOWARD
THE RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC
WE'RE WE'RE JUST REALLY
BEGINNING THESE CONVERSATIONS
AGAIN. BUT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
KEEP THE COMMITTEE UPDATED AS
THEY PROGRESS. I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT I WILL SAY THAT-
THE YOUR STATEMENT INCLUDED THE
NEED FOR CONSOLIDATION AND
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT TROUBLING
GIVEN THAT WE'VE COME. WE HAVE
COME TO THAT AGREEMENT. I YEARS
AGO- AND SO I JUST WANT TO PUSH
BACK ON ON THAT PART AND I DON'T
WANT THAT TO BE WITH THE LACES.
FURTHER AS WE DO THIS THIS WORK
OUT THERE. ON SO A DISBURSING
AND THEN. ADD A NUMBER OF OUR
PANELISTS TALKED ABOUT THE MODEL
FOR THE REIMBURSEMENT MODEL THAT
WE HAVE AND HOW IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK FOR A LOT OF OUR-
VICTIMS. OUT THERE US IS THERE
LOWER INCOME SO WE TALK ABOUT
EQUITY THE MODEL BECOMES
CUMBERSOME. AND LACKS EQUITY.
ARE THERE ARE THERE OTHER PLACES
WHERE WE HAVE A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF MODEL THAT'S BEING USED- OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW OR- CAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- CAL THE
CV SPEAK TO ANY CONSIDERATIONS
THAT WAY AGAINST YOU SEEN EVERY
ENFORCEMENT MODEL AND I ALSO
WANT TO BE FAIR. ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT TO BE CIVIL. DEVIN CLARK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY OTHER
MODELS THIS TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONSIDER PROPOSALS THAT COULD
STRENGTHEN VICTIM SERVICES AND
RESULT IN DEFICIENCIES FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT- AND BE HAPPY TO BE
CONSTRUED BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR STAFF
TO EVALUATE THAT. DO ANY OF THE
PANELISTS KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
MODELS OUT THERE. OR ANY ISSUES
WITH USING A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
MODEL THAT THAT REIMBURSEMENT.
WELL I CAN SAY THAT- AGAIN THE
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER MALL WELL
THERE'S A TEAM IN THE STATE I
WILL SAY THAT MOST OF THEM
REALLY ARE NOT FUND IT UP TO THE
LEVEL THAT WE THINK THEY SHOULD
BE FUNDED YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
SMALLER PROGRAMS ARE ONLY FUNDED
AT ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S CERTAINLY IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO RUN AN ENTIRE
CENTER- AND THERE ARE SOME THAT.
OF SO OUT OF THE EIGHTEEN TRC'S
I THINK OF THERE WOULD BE ANY
BECAUSE THE MODEL HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO BE SO EFFECTIVE TO BE
ABLE TO. IMPROVE THE FUNDING FOR
THOSE EIGHTEEN TO YOUR SEASON
ALSO TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE
FUNDING MORE AVAILABLE FOR
ADDITIONAL TIER CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I THINK YOU MIGHT MY
LAST QUESTION IS- ABOUT THE-
COMMENTS THAT WAS BY A MEMBER OF
THE PANEL IS BROUGHT UP THE FACT
THAT- WITHIN THEIR VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS COMPENSATION FOR NON
COOPERATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
I KNOW THAT THOSE NUMBERS.
POLICE THOSE COMMENTED THAT THEY
IT HAS GONE DOWN BUT IT'S STILL
EXIST. OUT THERE- THE FEDERAL
LOCAL FIX ACT WHICH PASSED. JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLARIFY THE
STATE ARE NOT REQUIRED UNDER
FEDERAL RULES TO THE NIGHT
VICTIMS. OR SURVIVORS FOR
COMPENSATION FOR NON COOPERATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. EIGHTEEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STATES TO CHANGE
THESE POLICIES I KNOW THAT- TO
REMOVE THE LAMPERT'S FROM
ACQUIRE MANY TO STATUTORY CHANGE
BUT ARE THERE ANY STEPS THAT
CALVI CV CAN MAKE TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY OR THE
REGULATIONS TO EASE THIS
REQUIREMENT- AND IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT- CAL THE CV IS
DOING. AS YOU NOTED AS A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS ARE TOP
ECB- CORPORATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS
ALREADY WRITTEN INTO STATUTE FOR
CERTAIN CRIMES. SUCH AS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT BUT WE
BELIEVE ANY AND FURTHER CHANGES
WOULD REQUIRE A STATUTORY CHANGE. AT WHERE IS THERE ANY- IS
ANYTHING THEY COULD ADMINISTER
LEAD TO EASE THE REQUIREMENT
ADDITIONALLY ARE. YOUR HANDS ARE
COMPLETELY TIED I GUESS IS MY
QUESTION. YEAH WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
MIND YOU KNOW OUR THEM READING
OF THE STATUTE IS THAT- AGAIN
OPERATION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
KEY TO WANT IN AT THE END OF THE
HAVE AN APPROVED APPLICATION.
WHAT ABOUT WOULD BE ANOTHER WAS
THE ONE OF THE COMMENTS MADE
ABOUT THAT DECISION BE MADE
REALLY EARLY ON AND THE PROCESS-
BUT THEN WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT THE
TRC'S WE HEARD THAT. VICTIMS
SCHOOL. ACCESSING THE TEAR
CEASE- SERVICES WERE MORE LIKELY
TO INCREASE THEIR THEIR
COOPERATION WITH. WITH LAW AND
ENFORCEMENT- JUST WONDERING IF
THERE'S I UNDERSTAND THE PART OF
THE LEGISLATIVE DUTIES TO LOOK
AT THAT YOU IN THAT LETTER THAT
LIFE ON US AND THAT YOU AND
THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR US TO
WORK THERE MAYBE THIS YEAR- AND
SO- I APPRECIATE THAT BUT JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S- MORE
CREATIVE WAYS TO. TO THINK ABOUT
THIS THAT THIS WOMAN FROM FROM
YOUR AT THE SIDE OF THINGS. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING R. AND IT. YOU
KNOW IT'S THE WE WANT TO GET
APPROVED APPLICATIONS BECAUSE
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO THEN BEGIN
TO GET HAVE BILLS REIMBURSED-
AND PART OF THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IS MAKING SURE THAT A CRIME WAS
COMMITTED THAT WAS A QUALIFYING
CRIME. AND THAT THERE WEREN'T
IT'S GENERATING CIRCUMSTANCES-
SUCH AS CORPORATIONS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUR INVOLVEMENT THAT
WOULD MAKE AN APPLICATION AN
APPLICANT IN ELIGIBLE- SO THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
WORK THROUGH AND EVERY DAY HERE
COUNTY CD DO TRY TO HELP AS MANY
PEOPLE AS WE CAN BUT ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT WORK CORRECTLY.
APPLYING THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS SURROUNDING THE
PROGRAM THAT CURRENTLY ITS LAST
. I'D SAY THAT- I BELIEVE THE
STATUTE ALSO- I WAS- THAT A
MEDICAL REPORT CAN BE ACCEPTED
IN LIEU OF A POLICE REPORT. SO
IF SOMEONE IS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED. AND THEY GO TO A
HOSPITAL THE HOSPITAL IS ABLE TO
SUBMIT RECORDS- AND THAT THAT
SHOULD COUNT INSTEAD OF A POLICE
REPORT- BUT NOT. ALL THE TIME
MY- WITH SOME OF THE TIME THOSE
RECORDS ARE REALLY NOT ACCEPTED.
SO IT IS SOMEWHAT OF A- OF LACK
OF CLARITY. HOW THAT IS BEING
INTERPRETED AND I CERTAINLY
THINK THAT IS A LITTLE BIT OF
WIGGLE ROOM THAT WE AS- MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
SHOULD HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY I
HAVE SEEN THIS PERSON AND I
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE A VICTIM
OF A VIOLENT CRIME. SO I THINK
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE STATURE TO
CHANGE. I THINK IF THERE COULD
BE SOME MORE EDUCATION- THAT CAL
THE CITY COULD OF PROVIDE
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. SO THAT THEY KNOW
THAT WE CAN SUBMIT- THAT KIND OF
DOCUMENTATION IN LIEU OF A
POLICE. REPORT I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. RIGHT SURVIVOR
REMARKS AS ARE FOR SPECIFIC
CRIMES- THAT ARE LAID OUT AND
STATUTES SO THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT. ARE
AREAS WHERE WE CAN CHANGE MENTAL
HEALTH STATEMENT OR OR MEDICAL
PROVIDER STATEMENT AND BLUE. OF
A CRIME REPORT- AND STATEMENT
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT IT DOES
NOT APPLY TO EVERY CRIME. OKAY
THE THANK YOU FOR. FOR THAT I
WOULD HAVE AT. YOU KNOW AND EVEN
WHEN WE DO HAVE THE STATUS IN
THESE CASES LIKE YOU TO SET UP-
THE COMMENT ABOUT NEEDING MAYBE
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION- BOTH TO
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND THE SAME
THING TO VICTIMS I DO
APPRECIATE. THE WORK THAT'S GONE
ON TO UPDATE THE WEBSITE TO HAVE
LOCATIONS THERE. ARE THE TEARS
HE SERVED IN OUR REGION SO I DO
A KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
IMPROVEMENTS IN A LOT OF WAYS
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING THE WAY-
AND SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT WORK AND WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I THINK FOR
MYSELF IT'S ALWAYS THAT NORTH
STAR OF. YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
AND BE LEADERS AND INNOVATIVE
AND- AND OTHER WAYS WHEN THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT HELPING THE
VICTIMS HE'LL IS NOT JUST
INDIVIDUAL BUT- REALLY AFFECTS
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY. OUT THERE-
AND I APOLOGIZE I SAID THAT I
WAS MY LAST QUESTION BUT- THIS
REALLY WILL BE THE LEVEL AND-
THE PATTERN- THE WE HAVEN'T
RAISED THE CAP SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THAT'S OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND SO THANK YOU FOR OF
THAT WORK TO START TO LOOK INTO
RAISING BOTH CAPS DO WE HAVE A
MORE IS THERE A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS MORE
THAN JUST EVERY TWENTY YEARS OUT
THERE WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
COST OF LIVING AND JUST THINGS
IN GENERAL SO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND- ARE GENERALLY BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THERE'S ASPIRIN
INCREASES YOUR TRY STARTING TO
ADDRESS THAT. BUT I JUST AS IN
GENERAL YOU KNOW HOW TO ENSURE
THAT IT DOESN'T TAKE US TWENTY
YEARS TO BE LOOKING AT THESE
THINGS. AND THE A TF- YES THANK
YOU I'M SORRY- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MIGHT BE ABLE TO WEIGH
IN AS WELL BUT AND I THINK THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT. SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED. CALLINGS MISTER
BANKS FOR YOUR FLOOR. YES THIS
IS A- YOU MENTIONED ABOUT
COOPERATION OR LACK THEREOF
COOPERATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND WHAT CAME TO MIND.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
VICTIM ASSISTANCE- JUST
RECENTLY. AFTER AMERICAN MALE
WHO IS IN HIS HOME- NO KNOCK
WARRANT. LAFOREST WE WENT IN AND
KILLED NOT ONLY WAS NOT THE
PERSON THEY WERE LOOKING FOR- IT
SEEMED AS IF THE CHIEF OF POLICE
IN THAT PARTICULAR AGENCY. WAS
ALMOST LIKE THIS IS JUST A
CASUALTY OF WAR. AND PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
NOT CASUALTIES OF WAR WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAKES A MISTAKE. AND
ALSO APPEARED AS IF THERE WAS
GOING TO BE A COVER UP. OF THAT
INCIDENT WHICH IS VERY
DISTURBING. SAME THAT THE
PROCEDURES THAT WE USE WERE
CORRECT. AND WE HAD AN ACCIDENT. IN THAT CASE IT WERE TO HAPPEN
HERE. BOB I COULD SEE WHERE.
BECAUSE OF FUTURE LITIGATION-
UNIONS GETTING INVOLVED
PROTECTING OFFICERS THAT YOU MAY
NOT GET COOPERATION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CONVERSELY THE
FAMILY MAY NOT WANT TO COOPERATE
WITH SOMEONE THAT MAY HAVE
KILLED. THEIR LOVED ONE AND SO
HOW WOULD THAT PERSON WHO NOW IS
LOST THEIR LOVED ONE IN A TRAGIC
ACCIDENT. NOW ACCESS THIS IF
THEY NEED COOPERATION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
ANY OF THESE ON AND I WOULD ALSO
ADMIT AS OF FORMALLY WORKED IN A
MORTUARY FOR TEN YEARS- SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED IS WAY TOO LITTLE
TO PAY FOR FUNERAL ESPECIALLY OF
ONE AT THE LAST MINUTE SO WHAT
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT. FULLY
COOPERATING OR BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTIGATION IT MAY NOT BE IN
IRAN FOR BEST INTEREST TO HELP
WITH THIS. ANYONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QESTION
WOULD YOU YOU KNOW TRY TO LOOK
AT THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING THE
CRIME AND WE WERE COMPENSATING
FOR THE CRIME THAT OCCURRED
RATHER THAN THE INJURY SO THOSE
ARE TWO IMPORTANT POINTS THAT I
WANT TO MAKE OBVIOUSLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IT'S A VERY
SPECIFIC INCIDENT- AND I WOULD
BE ABLE TO TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW
THAT WOULD WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT WE DO. MAKE EVERY
EFFORT IN OUR AND REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS THAT COME IN TO
HELP AS MANY VICTIMS AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. WITH WITH THAT
SAID THEN- WAS LIKE. FIFTY ONE
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND DENIALS
AND PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WIDER
DENIED CAN YOU GET THAT
INFORMATION LEADS TO THIS
COMMITTEE WHAT ARE THE CRITERIA
FOR DENIAL SO WE CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT. WHY YOU DENIED SO THAT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO HELP YOU WITH
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF NILES.
THERE IS SOME INFORMATION ON
YOUR- I BELIEVE IT BUT IF YOU
ON'T HAVE WHAT YOU NEED OR HAVE
BEEN. ADDED TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU.
AND I'M GOOD AT SOME PAGE SIX OF
OUR AGENDA WE HAVE SOME
INFORMATION THERE. WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO GET SOME OF THE DATA
THAT YOU HAVE ON PAGE SIX- SO
ABOUT THE NILES BASED ON RACE
WITH GREAT RACIAL DEMOGRAPHICS
AS WELL- DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
IS OPTIONAL WHEN WE RECEIVE
APPLICATIONS BUT IF WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. MISTER JONES SAWYER
POLITICS PLEASE CONTINUE. I
WOULD LIKE TO BREAK DOWN I MEAN
LACK OF PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE OF THE LACK OF
COOPERATION I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
WHAT. BASED ON ON QUESTIONS THAT
YOU ASK THEM WHAT WERE THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU FELT THERE'S
LACK OF COOPERATION DO YOU KNOW
WHY THEY DIDN'T COOPERATE LACK
OF COOPERATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO YOU KNOW WHY THAT
THAT'S WHERE I'M GETTING TO THE
THERE MAY BE. UNDERLYING REASONS
FOR ALL OF THIS INSTEAD OF JUST
SAYING. NO WE SHOULD BE A LITTLE
PROACTIVE ABOUT GETTING TO EAT
YES. AS YOU WANT TO BUT WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WE SEND LETTERS
WITH EVERY DENIAL EXPLAINING
VERY CLEARLY WHAT INFORMATION
WERE MISSING- AND WE ALSO. WORK
WITH AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
INFORMATION WE MAY NEED IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO PROCESS AN
APPLICATION- IT'S SO. WEIRD AND
SO IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
THE TOO MANY REMOTE CERTAINLY
TRY TO DO SO. OKAY WOULD BEGIN
ADAMANT BELIEVER IT BUT I THINK
WANTED TO SPEAKERS EITHER DOCTOR
RODRIGUEZ R. DR. BOTH LOWRY BOTH
. WATER BOTTOM SAID THAT VICTIMS
DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WERE DENIED
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING. THE
QUESTION. AND SO- IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE A SAMPLE OF WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE SENDING OUT. TO VICTIMS
WHO DENIED THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL HELPFUL. ABSOLUTELY. AND
JUST TO FOLLOW UP WITH MR JONES
SAWYER SAID WE WOULD LIKE THAT
THE STATURE IN THE STATURE
REQUIRES CALVI CB TO CONSIDER
MITIGATING FACTORS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CORROBORATION WAS
REASONABLE AND CAL THE CITY HAS
PRETTY BROAD DISCRETION LAID OUT
IN THE STATUTE- DO WE HAVE SOME
SORT OF A PROCESS OR TRAINING
FOR STAFF THAT THEY ARE
PROACTIVELY LOOKING INTO THESE
MITIGATING FACTORS. WHEN SOMEONE
IS NOT COOPERATING. BUT WE DO
HAVE. DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT
WE LOOKED AT AND WE TRY TO LOOK
AT THAT WHICH HOLIDAY OF THE
SITUATION WE'RE NOT JUST LOOKING
AT WHAT- WE FIND ON THEIR
APPLICATIONS WE ABSOLUTELY DO
YOU REACH OUT TO VETERANS TO
TALK TO THEM MORE ABOUT WHAT
THEY'VE GIVEN US IF THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN FOR. YOU
RECEIVED FROM EITHER THEM OR FOR
SOMEONE ELSE SO AND THIS IS NOT
A MATTER SIMPLY LOOK APPLICATION
AND CHECKING OUT POTS- AS I'VE
SAID BEFORE THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
HERE ARE VERY DEDICATED TO THE
WORK THAT THEY DO. A LOT OF THEM
CHANGED ARE HERE BECAUSE THEY
REALLY WANT TO HELP VICTIMS- AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. WE
TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY. DOES ANYONE HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY WELL I'D
LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY A
CONSOLIDATION PLAN I THINK
THAT'S PART OF ALSO HELPING TO
HAVE A MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH-
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE AND AT
THE- HELLO YES US A LOT OF THE
PLATE AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A LOT ON THEIR
PLATE AS WE HAVE. YEAR ROUND
FIRE SEASON OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS AND SO FORTH AND SO I
HOPE THAT. WE ARE ABLE TO MOVE
IN A MORE JUDICIOUS MANNER ON
THIS CONSOLIDATION PLANS THAT WE
CAN BETTER SERVE. VICTIMS OUT
THERE I DO APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE I DO
APPRECIATE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO INCREASE SOME OF THESE CAPS
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS- TO HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT WORKS BETTER FOR A FOR ALL
OF OUR- CRIME VICTIMS OUT THERE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO HELP WITH SOME
OF THE STATUTORY CHANGES THAT
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TO THE PANELISTS.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TRY NEXT-
PANEL. WE ARE LOOKING AT POLICE
OFFICER IN THE CERTIFICATION.
AND THE AGENDA WE HAVE IT. THANK
YOU WE HAVE TO OUR PANELISTS ON
MANY OF IT IS FOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. AND JESSICA PETERS
WITH THE LISTED OF ANALYST'S
OFFICE. YES GOOD GO AHEAD AND
SPEAK. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME RESEARCH. HERE YOU OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MAY I PRESENT I SERVED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR POST
AS WE ARE COMMONLY REFERRED TO.
I'M JOINED AT THE HEARING. MY
COLLEAGUE JACKI NELSON. THE
BUREAU CHIEF LEADING THE HOST SB
TWO IMPLEMENTATION TEAM. THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
AT THIS HEARING. I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS SB TWO IMPLEMENTATION IN
TWO PARTS. FIRST JUST A FEW KEY
POINTS ON WHAT WE'VE DONE AND
WHERE WE STAND. AND SECOND THE
REASONS FOR THE RESOURCE REQUEST
IN THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
FOR YOU. FARGAS THIRD PRIOR TO
IT SB TWO BEING SIGNED INTO LAW.
WE DESIGNATED A PART TIME TEAM
TO HOLD MONTHLY DISCUSSIONS ON
IMPLEMENTATION SHOULD THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. ON NOVEMBER FIRST
WE DESIGNATED A FULL TIME TEAM
TO SB TWO IMPLEMENTATION. THE
TEAM CURRENTLY CONSISTS OF EIGHT
FULL TIME PERSONNEL AND SEVERAL
PART TIME PERSONAL. IN DECEMBER
WE ISSUE BOTH INTO THE FIELD
ADVISING THE NEW PIECE OF
ADVISING OF THE NEW PEACE
OFFICER SELECTION STANDARDS
MANDATED AB EIGHTY NINE. AND SB
TWO. WE'RE IN THE FINAL STAGES
OF UPDATING THE POST PEACE
OFFICER PERSONAL HISTORY
STATEMENT. AND ARE NOW UPDATING
THE BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
MANUAL TO COMPLY WITH THE
RELEVANT SB TWO REQUIREMENTS. WE
DRAFTED AN INVESTIGATIVE POLICY
MANUAL WHICH ENCOMPASSES BOTH
INVESTIGATIONS COMPLETED BY
POST. AND THOSE COMPLETED BY
AGENCIES AND REVIEWED BY POST.
WE HELD TWO WORKSHOPS IN JANUARY
TO IDENTIFY THE FACTORS TO BE
CONSIDERED. WHEN REVIEWING
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT OR
DECERTIFICATION. THE FIRST
WORKSHOP WAS HELD WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND THE
SECOND WITH ADVOCATES FROM A
LIST PREPARED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD'S OFFICE. TO GAIN
KNOWLEDGE FROM OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. WE HELD ONE ON ONE
LICENSING A DECERTIFICATION
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FOLLOWING
STATES. WASHINGTON OREGON NEVADA
UTAH ARIZONA TENNESSEE NEW YORK
AND MASSACHUSETTS. OUR COMPUTER
PROGRAMMERS HAVE COMPLETED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN ONLINE
PLATFORM FOR RECEIPT OF
COMPLAINTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC A PLATFORM MODELED AFTER
THE EXISTING PLATFORM USED BY
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. WE'VE ALSO
SUBMITTED A STATE ONE BUSINESS
ANALYSIS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF TECHNOLOGY TO
CAPTURE AND MANAGE DATA
ENUMERATED IN SB TWO. OUR STAFF
HAS DESIGNED A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
FORTY HOUR TRAINING COURSE
MANDATED FOR MEMBERS OF THE NEW
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS ACCOUNT
OF A- PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY BOARD. A TRAINING
REQUIREMENT WE ALSO EXPECT TO
PLACE ON POST STAFF MEMBERS
ASSIGNED TO THE NEW STANDARDS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY DIVISION. WE
ANTICIPATE ROLLING OUT TO PILOT
TRAINING COURSES THIS FALL. THE
IMPLEMENTATION TEAM HAS DRAFTED
TWENTY NEW REGULATIONS TO
ADDRESS THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB
TWO AMENDED SEVEN REGULATIONS
AND WILL PROPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF ONE. REGULATION WE SENT TO
YEAH STORY WE SET AN INTERNAL
DEADLINE THE PUBLISHED PUBLISHED
THE BOOK OF THOSE REGULATIONS
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. NO LATER
THAN MARCH FIFTEENTH. WE
ANTICIPATE PROPOSED PROPOSED
REGULATIONS BEING COVERED BY THE
POST COMMISSION ON MAY TWENTY
FIFTH. OUR CURRENT YOUR HIRING
STRATEGY IS TO INITIATE HIRING
FOR ANY TWENTY FOUR POSITION AND
FOR H. R. POSITIONS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT SB TWO
IMPLEMENTATION. YOUR TWENTY FOUR
WILL ASSIST WITH REGULATIONS AND
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT RELATED SB
TWO. AND WILL HATE HELP STAND UP
A LEGAL UNIT. EACH OUR POSITIONS%
WILL SUPPORT THE FUTURE HIRING
OF PERSONNEL SHOULD THIS BE C.
P. B. APPROVED. OKAY SITTING ON
A HIRING FOR. NEWS HR STAFF WILL
HELP US PREPARE FOR THE
POTENTIAL HIRING REQUESTED IN
THIS BCP. WITHOUT HAVING FOR
ADDITIONAL HR PERSONNEL ARE H.
R. UNIT WILL BE STAFFED WITH
NINE PERSONNEL READY AND ABLE TO
PROCESS LARGE SCALE HIRING.
FURTHERMORE WE WILL ADVERTISE
MANY OF THE POSITIONS CALL FOR
IN THIS B. C. P. IN THE SPRING.
WITH THE CABBIE OUT TO
APPLICANTS OF THE HIRING WILL BE
CONTINGENT UPON THE FINAL
OUTCOME OF THE BCP. IN TERMS OF
THEIR REQUEST IN THIS B. C. P.
WE'VE DONE PROJECTIONS ON THE
VOLUME OF INCOMING DATA. THE
NUMBER OF REVIEWS WHICH WILL
TAKE PLACE. AND THE NUMBER OF
THE CERTIFICATIONS. WE'VE
UTILIZED SOME OF OUR OWN
EXISTING DATA AS WELL AS DATA
FROM OTHER STATES. TO MAKE THESE
PROJECTIONS. THE CHALLENGES SUCH
THAT POST R. S. B. TWO. HAS NOT
BEEN REQUIRED OR PERMITTED TO
COLLECT THE DATA LISTED IN THE
LEGISLATION. TO COMPOUND THE
ISSUE EACH STATE HANDLES
DECERTIFICATION DIFFERENTLY WITH
THE BULK OF STATES PROCESSING
REVOCATIONS BASED ON CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS OR SUSTAINED
INTERNAL INVESTIGATIONS. IN
OTHER WORDS COMPARING DATA FROM
OTHER STATES IS IN PERFECT. THUS
WE UNDERSTAND THAT UNTIL WE HAVE
DATA WE MUST BE OPEN TO MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS. WE ARE HAPPY TO GO
INTO DETAIL ON OUR PROJECTIONS
AND HOW WE PLAN TO DEAL WITH THE
WORKLOAD. TO ACCOMPLISH THE
MANDATES IN SB TWO. A. B. C. D.
ADDRESSES AMONG OTHER THINGS THE
NEED FOR PERSONNEL RESOURCES
TECHNOLOGY AND OFFICE SPACE. BCP
REQUEST FUNDING FOR ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN NEW STAFF
POSITIONS TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TECHNOLOGY IN YEAR ONE AND
ONE MILLION I'M GOING. AND ONE
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING FOR
OFFICE SPACE. THE REQUEST FOR
PERSONAL RESOURCES WILL ENABLE
POSTED CREATING LEGAL UNIT
STAFFED BY ANALYSTS AND
ATTORNEYS AND AS MUCH AS WE DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE THE LEGAL
STAFF. LEGAL UNIT WILL REVIEW
PROPOSED DECERTIFICATION
MATTERS. AND WILL WORK WITH THE
NEW ADVISORY BOARD. THE
COMMISSION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
WHO WILL BE CONDUCTING
EVIDENTIARY HEARINGS. BCP ALSO
CALLS FOR A NUMBER OF KEY UNITS
SUCH AS AN INTAKE UNIT TO
RECEIVE TRACK AND FOLLOWED TO
COMPLETION ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT TO FIND IN SB
TWO. A STANDALONE CERTIFICATE
UNITY ISSUED AND
ADMINISTRATIVELY REVOKE
CERTIFICATES. A UNIT DEDICATED
TO THE REVIEW OF MATTERS
PERTAINING TO EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE AND TWO OTHER UNITS TO
REVIEW ALL OTHER MATTERS OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. FUNDING FOR
STAFF POSITIONS IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE. THE STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS LISTED IN THE B. C.
P. ONE ABLE CLOSE TO FINALISE
IMPLEMENTATION IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO. AND WILL ENABLE THE STATE TO
MAINTAIN A ROBUST PROGRAMS YEAR
AFTER YEAR. A. B. C. P. ALSO
REQUESTS FUNDING FOR TECHNOLOGY
AND ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT IS NOTED
EXCHANGING DATA WITH OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS MUST BE
DONE ELECTRONICALLY. S. B. C. P.
REQUEST FUNDING FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF A TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM. TO RECEIVE INFORMATION
CONDUCT REVIEWS. AND ACTIVISTS
OCCASIONS REFORM CASE MANAGEMENT
. AS WELL AS A LOT AS WELL AS TO
ELECTRONICALLY STORED
DECERTIFICATION INFORMATION FOR
THIRTY YEARS HAS CALLED FOR AN
S. B. TWO. IN TERMS OF THE
OFFICE SPACE CLOSE IS CURRENTLY
STAFFED BY ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE PERSONNEL. LOCATED%
IN ONE PHYSICAL OFFICE SPACE.
SECURING SPACE TO CO LOCATE THE
NEW DIVISION IS AN IMPORTANT
PRIORITY. ENTERTAINING ONE
SINGLE OFFICE SPACE WILL
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY. WILL
ALLOW CODES MANAGEMENT TO
EFFECTIVELY MARSHAL RESOURCES
WHEN NECESSARY. WITH THAT MADAM
CHAIR WE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO TESTIFY- COMMITTEE. RIGHT
TO TESTIFY TO YOUR COMMITTEE ON
SORRY AND WE STAND READY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU REPORT QUESTIONS
WILL HEAR FROM OUR SECOND
PANELIST WITH THE ALLEY OF
OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE OB
PRESENTING FOR- JESSICA PETERS
TODAY. WE DOWANT TO NOTE THAT
POSE HAS DONE QUITE A BIT OF
WORK TO BEGIN SB TWO
IMPLEMENTATIONS SUCH AS
CONSULTING WITH OTHER STATES AS
WAS NOTED WE DO HOWEVER
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT POST TO SUBMIT AN UPDATED
PROPOSAL THIS SPRING THAT
ADDRESSES TWO CONCERNS WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WITH THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL. OUR FIRST CONCERN IS
THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
APPEAR TO REQUEST RESOURCES FOR
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF SB TWO
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIFICALLY
HOSTED INFORMED US THAT THEIR
REQUEST IS BASED ON AN ESTIMATED
NUMBER OF ALLEGATIONS. THAT POST
EXPECTS TO GET IN THE FUTURE BUT
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT AN
INITIAL SURGE OF WORKLOAD IT
WILL GET FROM ALLOCATE
ALLEGATIONS. OF MISCONDUCT THAT
OCCURRED IN THE PAST. IN
ADDITION. HE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR ONE TIME
CERTIFICATION WORKLOAD TO ISSUE
PROOF OF ELIGIBILITY
CERTIFICATES TO OFFICERS WHO ARE
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO HAVE A
BASIC CERTIFICATE. OR OTHER
SECOND MAJOR CONCERN IS THAT
THERE WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES FACING
COAST- MOST NOTABLY AS WAS
INDICATED POST WILL MEET TO
ROUGHLY DOUBLE ITS STAFFING BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ONLY SIX MONTHS AFTER RECEIVING
FUNDING IN THE STATE BUDGET.
ALSO HOSTS CURRENT OFFICE SPACE
IS INSUFFICIENT AND TO
ACCOMMODATE THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION WILL NEED ADDITIONAL
OFFICE SPACE WHICH THEY'RE
REQUESTING. OTHER DGS HAS
INFORMED THEM THAT ALL OF LIKELY
TAKE A YEAR OR MORE TO SECURE.
ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE. IN
ADDITION I WAS WAS IN THE POST
WILL NEED TO OBTAIN IN TAKES ON
INTAKE SOFTWARE SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE REPORTS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND HAVE
THE SYSTEM OPERATIONAL ON
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT OPPOSED
TO SUBMIT A REVISED PROPOSAL AT
THE MAY REVISION THAT PROVIDES
AN ESTIMATE OF THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH PAST ALLEGATIONS
OF MISCONDUCT. AND THE PROOF OF
ELIGIBILITY ISSUE ONCE AND ALSO
DETAILS HOW. WILL ADDRESS THIS
WORKLOAD AND DESCRIBES HOW POST
WILL GO ABOUT. ADDRESSING THE
IMPLEMENTATION. CHALLENGES
DISCUSSED ABOUT. I'M NOT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
FOR THAT CAN-MISTER ALVAREZ-
COMMON RESPOND TO THE ELIAS'S
CONCERN ABOUT HURRYING OVER A
HUNDRED POSITIONS IN SIX MONTHS
AND HOW WILL BE PREPARED FOR
THAT. YES MADAM CHAIR SO WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
POSITIONS ON BOARD AS OF JANUARY
ONE WE DO FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO
HAVE. SOME OF THE POSITIONS ON
BOARD TO PROVIDE TRAINING. AND
TO HELP US MOVE ALONG BUT IN
TERMS OF YOU NOW SUS OF DATA
AND- THE INVESTIGATIONS WILL BE
CONDUCTED. THERE IS NO DATE
UNTIL JANUARY ONE SO WE DO NOT
FEEL THAT WE NEED TO HAVE ALL OF
THOSE STAFF MEMBERS ON BOARD BY
JANUARY ONE- WE DO FEEL LIKE WE
WILL NEED SOME AND THAT IS. GEN
STARTING IN THE SPRING. HIRING A
NUMBER OF THEM IN JULY ON. JULY
ONE SHOULD THE BCP BE APPROVED.
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE- IS
MENTIONED THAT WE NEED EVERYBODY
ON ON BOARD. I'M ON DAY ONE. AND
SO WHY IS THE REQUEST OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST ASKING US FOR ALL
OF THE FOR THE FUNDING FOR ALL
THE POSITIONS VERSUS A STAGGERED
APPROACH. WELL WE CAN DEFINITELY
ADD. YOU KNOW REVISE IT FOR A
STAGGERED APPROACH BUT THAT IS
OUR STRATEGY AT THIS POINT- IS
TO STAGGER THE HIRING- BETWEEN
NOW AND JANUARY ONE- I. I DON'T
WANT TO GIVE PRECISE NUMBERS BUT
I PRESUME THAT IF WE- IF WE ARE
A 50% JANUARY ONE THEN I THINK
WE'RE IN PRETTY GOOD SHAPE. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO REVISED
THIS PROPOSAL COME. FROM FUTURE-
WE WELL WE DO HAVE A SURPLUS AND
THE BUDGET WE WANT TO BE
JUDICIOUS WITH THESE ALLOCATIONS
AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE BEING USED
APPROPRIATELY- AND IF WE ARE
LOOKING AT A STAGGERED APPROACH
WHICH IS FINE MORE PRAGMATIC I
THINK OUR BUDGET SHOULD REFLECT
THAT AS WELL- THANK YOU FOR
THAT. DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. RIGHT WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION- SB
TWO IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I THINK WELL
COMMITTED TO A SUCCESSFUL
WORKING WITH. WITH YOUR AGENCY
TO ENSURE WE ARE SUCCESSFUL AND
SO LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ON THE FIFTH. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO A THIRD ISSUE ISSUE WHICH
IS. OFFICER WELLNESS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- FOR THIS TESTIMONY
I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
ANDREW AND DANSA WHO IS
COORDINATING OUR EFFORTS ON POST
WELLNESS TRAINING. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
SECOND BCP. WILL BE BRIEF AND
WILL ADDRESS WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
TERMS OF WALLACE. AND SECOND THE
REASONS FOR THE RESOURCE REQUEST
IN THIS P. C. P. I WAY
BACKGROUND. AB EIGHTEEN TWELVE
IN JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
MANDATED POST CREATED
INNOVATIONS GRANT PROGRAMS. WERE
IGP. IN HOPES OF REDUCING
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. AS
PART OF THE IGP POST WAS
DIRECTED TO DISTRIBUTE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OVER A THREE
YEAR TIME PERIOD IN TRAINING
GRANTS. TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND OTHER ENTITIES ONE
OF THE FIVE TOPIC AREAS DEFINED
IN AB EIGHTEEN TWELVE WITH PEACE
OFFICER WELLNESS. POST COMPLETED
THREE SEPARATE ROUNDS OF IGP
FUNDING OVER TWO YEAR TIME
PERIOD. AS A RESULT A TOTAL OF
TEN GRANTS TOTALING ONE MILLION
1-008-400-0900 EIGHTY FOUR
DOLLARS WERE ISSUED FOR PEACE
OFFICER WELLNESS TRAINING. A
TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE STUDENTS RECEIVE
WELLNESS TRAINING. THE FINAL IGP
GRANTS EXPIRED ON DECEMBER
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
DURING THE INITIAL MONTHS OF
COVERAGE OF THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- SUBMITTED A B. C. D.
IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOR AN ONLINE TRAINING PROGRAM
TO MAYOR THE FIVE TOPIC
REQUIREMENTS. IN A. B. EIGHTEEN
TWELVE A PROGRAM WE CALLED THE
DISTANCE LEARNING GRANT PROGRAM
OR DEAL G. P. THE PEACE THE
BASIC HE WAS A BETTER THAN AS
MUCH AS CLASSROOM BASED TRAINING
WAS ALL BUT ELIMINATED. IN THE
ENTIRETY OF TWENTY TWENTY. BCP
WAS APPROVED. AND THE FUNDING
WAS INCORPORATED INTO THE FY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. THE GRANT RECIPIENTS
WERE LIMITED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENTS IN ACADEMIA. AS PART
OF THE DEAL D. O. G. P. S. WAS
GRANTED AUTHORITY TO DISTRIBUTE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FIVE TOPIC AREAS ONE OF WHICH
BEING WELLNESS. AS A RESULT A
TOTAL OF FOUR WELLNESS GRANTS
TOTALING. NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS WERE ISSUED. A TOTAL OF
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
STUDENTS RECEIVED ONLINE
WELLNESS TRAINING. THE FINAL
DETAIL GP GRANT EXPIRED ON
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY RELEASED A PSA STYLE
VIDEO ON WALLACE CALLED SILENT
NO MORE. AS WELL AS A TWO HOUR
CLASSROOM BASED FACILITATED
TRAINING VIDEO. WE ARE SCHEDULED
TO HOLD WORKSHOPS TO CREATE A
MATT MANDATED BASIC. I'M SORRY
WE WORK SCHEDULED TO HOLD A
WORKSHOP TO CREATE MANDATED
BASIC ACADEMY CURRICULUM ON
WELLNESS IN LATE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY. UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
FORCED TO CANCEL THE WORKSHOP
DUE TO COVERT. WE'RE NOW
TENTATIVELY SCHEDULED TO START
UP AGAIN WITH THE WORKSHOP IN
MAY. SIMILARLY FOR THE LAST SIX
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN REVAMPING THE
DISPATCHER BASIC TRAINING
COURSE. THE NEW DISPATCHER BASIC
TRAINING WHICH IS MANDATED FOR
ALL NEW DISPATCHERS WILL INCLUDE
STANDARD CURRICULUM ON
DISPATCHER WELLNESS. WE HOPE TO
HAVE A DISPATCHER BASIC
CURRICULUM COMPLETED BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR. WITH THE PLANET
SOMETIME IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
. STARTING THE WELLNESS
DISCUSSION AT THE BEGINNING OF A
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
CAREERS AN IMPORTANT EARLY STEP
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THE
DEPARTMENT AND OUR COMMUNITY.
SUFFICE IT TO SAY FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON TRAINING DELIVERY.
THEREFORE THIS BCP SHIPS THE
PRIMARY FOCUS TO DEPARTMENT
SPECIFIC WELLNESS WORKSHOPS.
EACH DEPARTMENT IS DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF THE WELLNESS ISSUES
THEY FACE. SOME MAY FACE HIGH ON
DUTY INJURIES SUICIDES LACK OF
EFFECTIVE PEER SUPPORT PROGRAMS
AT CENTER AT CENTER. EACH
DEPARTMENT IS DIFFERENT THUS THE
DELIVERABLES OBJECTIVES AND
OUTCOMES FOR EACH DEPARTMENT
MUST BE TAILORED. HOST DESIRES
TO PARTNER WITH ACADEMIA
CLINICIANS AND EXPERTS IN THE
AREA OF WALLACE TO WORK WITH
INDIVIDUAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENTS TO CREATE OR IMPROVE
EXISTING PROGRAMS THEY MAY
ALREADY HAVE. BY LEVERAGING THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ACADEMIA.
CLINICIANS IN THE EXPERTS POST
WILL EVALUATE THE ISSUES. THE
DELIVERABLES CONDUCT FOLLOW
THROUGH. AND WILL DETERMINE THE
OUTCOMES- WILL ASSESS THE
OUTCOMES FOR EACH DEPARTMENT
PROJECT. WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
WHO ARE EMOTIONALLY AND
PHYSICALLY. OFFY NOT ONLY HELP
THEMSELVES IN THEIR DEPARTMENT.
BETTER BETTER FOR. OUR OUR
BETTER SERVICE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY. STATES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT TO BE TRUE AND
WE CAN GO INTO SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC STUDIES IF YOU'D LIKE.
THEREFORE THIS B. C. P.
ADDRESSES THE CONTINUE DELIVERY
OF TRAINING. BUT PERMITS THE
STATE A LEADERSHIP ROLE. TO WORK
WITH INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS TO
FURTHER THEIR INDIVIDUAL
WELLNESS OBJECTIVES. WITH THAT
MADAM CHAIR. WE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO TESTIFY. AND WE
STAND READY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE THE L. L. YES
TRUTH SO TO WORK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE FIND THAT
THE PROPOSAL COULD HAVE SOME
MERIT HOWEVER THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT THAT- WE- RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT POST
TO RESPOND TO BEFORE APPROVING
IT. SPECIFICALLY POSTED SHOULD
ANSWER THE QUESTION AS TO WHAT
THE PRIMARY GOALS OF THE PROGRAM
ARE WELL IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO IMPROVE
OFFICER WELLNESS THE MORE
SPECIFIC PRIMARY GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM REMAIN UNCLEAR SUCH AS
THE SPECIFIC TYPE OF WELLNESS
MENTAL PHYSICAL OR EMOTIONAL FOR
EXAMPLE THE PROPOSALS INTENDED
TO ADDRESS. IT'S ALSO NOT CLEAR
WHAT THE SPECIFIC PROBLEM POSED
IS ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE WITH THE
PROPOSAL. SAMPLE POST IDENTIFIED
WITH THE HIGHEST PRIORITY NEEDS
ARE FOR IMPROVING OFFICER AND
WELLNESS OR WHETHER THERE ARE
GAPS IN EXISTING WELLNESS
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT IT'S
ATTEMPTING TO FILL. IT'S ALSO
NOT EXACTLY CLEAR WHAT PRECISE
ACTIVITIES WOULD BE FUNDED IN
THE PROPOSAL PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THERE WHERE VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT. POST INDICATED
THEY MIGHT PURSUE BUT THE
SPECIFIC ONES THEY WILL PURSUE
REMAIN TO BE DETERMINED. IT'S
ALSO NOT CLEAR WHAT OUTCOMES
WILL BE EXPECTED FROM IT FOR
EXAMPLE THE NUMBER OF OFFICERS
THAT WILL BE REACHED OR THE
NUMBER OF IN TRAINING SET POSTED
TENDS TO OFFER. WE ALSO FROM I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR CLOSE
TO INDICATE TO THE LEGISLATURE
HOW IT WILL IMPLEMENT BOTH THIS
NEW PROGRAM IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE CHALLENGES IT WILL FACE AND
WANTING SB TWO. IT'S SUCH A- IF
THE ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS
ARE PROVIDED BY POSTING THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINES THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH ITS
OVER OVERALL GENERAL FUND
PRIORITIES AND IS LIKELY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THE LEGISLATURE
COULD. APPROVE THIS PROGRAM
HOWEVER TO THE EXTENT THAT POST
IS UNABLE TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RETRACTED REJECTED A
PROPOSAL WITHOUT. PREJUDICE AND
DIRECT POSED TO COME BACK WITH
A- MORE- FULLY DEVELOPED
PROPOSAL FOR CONSIDERATION AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR BUDGET. I THANK YOU
FOR THAT THIS THE INTERNET OFFER
A REBUTTAL YES PLEASE DO. THANK
YOU ANY FRIENDS OR THE PARTNER
FINANCE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- AS OPPOSED TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO AS WELL- MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER MADONNA'S ALSO
ON THE LINE AT THE PROPOSED
PROGRAM DOES HAVE FAIRLY
SPECIFIC GOALS WHICH PRODUCE
SUPPORT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. IN BUILDING THEIR
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY TO OFFER
BOTH INDIVIDUAL AND
ORGANIZATIONAL BONUS
PROGRAMMING- ONE OF THE PRIMARY
WAYS THIS WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED
IS BY HOSTING AGENCY WELLNESS
WORKSHOPS- IN FISCAL YEARS
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. A POST WILL
ALSO FACILITATE THE CREATION OF
WELL AS RELATED RESOURCE OF THE
MULTI MEDIA WHICH WILL BE- HOWLS
ON THEIR LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM AGGREGATING SEVENTY BEST
PRACTICES AND WORK WITH PARTNERS
ACADEMIA TO UNDERTAKE
EVALUATIONS THEY CAN SUPPORT
THAT IDENTIFICATION OF EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT POST IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED- WITH INSIGHT INTO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT GENCY
OPERATIONS IN THE EXTENT TO
WHICH A WELLNESS IS HANDLED
WITHIN THOSE AGENCIES- AS
DIRECTOR HOURS I THINK TOUCHED
ON POST HAS IDENTIFIED THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT GAP AMONG
AGENCIES AT AS IT PERTAINS TO
OFFERING- BOTH THE INDIVIDUAL
AND ORGANIZATIONAL LEVEL BONUS
PROGRAMS. AND NOW SPECIFICALLY
WITH THIS PROGRAM- IS TAILORED
TO ADDRESS- THE IDEA REALLY IS
TO CREATE ACCESS AT ONCE PROGRAM
THROUGH THE WORKSHOPS AND THEN
DISSEMINATE BEST PRACTICES THAT
DAY AND LAW ENFORCING AGENCIES
CAN TAKE TO BUILD THEIR OWN
LOCAL CAPACITY. AND WE REALLY
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SUPPORT- AN
OVERARCHING SHIFTED. TO
INCORPORATE WELLNESS. AT THAT IN
HERE PARTOF LAW FOR COURT. AND
TRAIN WHICH WILL. GO TO
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY OVERALL-
AND AGAIN TO TOUCH ON- THE L. A.
WAS POINT ABOUT ADDITIONAL
JUSTIFICATION ADMINISTRATION
REPORTED HAPPEN TO PROVIDE. ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
INVESTIGATION NECESSARY TO BOTH
BE ALEJO AND LEGISLATURE I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE INTENT IS
PROPOSED TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN
DELIVERING THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE-
IT'S ON A CIRCUIT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE- OF ON. THE DEPARTMENT
VARY SO MUCH AND SIZE CAPACITY-
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION ETCETERA-
AND POST IS REALLY THE STATEWIDE
LEADER IN A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SPACE AND IT HAS THE
ABILITY TO LEVERAGE. ITS
EXPERTISE TO INFORM THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THE LAST
POINT M. THE L. A. RAISE CONCERN
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
ONE'S PROGRAM SB TWO. AND AGAIN
INSTRUCTOR OVER AS NOTED POST
HAS SUBSTANTIAL EXPERIENCE
IMPLEMENTING TRAINING PROGRAMS-
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND I
WOULD ALSO NOTE STATE THIS WILL
BE DIFFERENT STAFF COMPLETELY-
YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
WELLNESS VERSES SB TWO- SO EVEN
THOUGH. SB TWO WITH OF COURSE
CRITICAL OF THE CENTER FOCUS-
POST DEFINITELY HAVE THE
CAPACITY. IN. THE ABILITY TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT BOTH. NOT
LOCAL COULD NOT COME AVAIL FOR
OTHER QUESTIONS- YEAH I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR MICHAEL. SO YOU
TALK ABOUT THE GOAL OF NC AT
INCREASING ACCESS AND-
FLEXIBILITY I THINK FOR US HERE
AND FOR MYSELF IT'S ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE EFFICACY.
AND THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING- YOU KNOW
TOWARDS WHILE LESSEN WHAT
EXACTLY THAT MEANS. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE CRIME PROGRAMS ALREADY THAT
EXIST AND TRAININGS DO YOU HAVE
DATA OR MEASUREMENTS OF HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE. I DON'T HAVE
ACCESS OKAY I BELIEVE MICHAEL
YEAH. I CAN SPEAK TO THE MANAGER
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME CENTER
AND ALSO I'M NOT A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON THE WEST COAST. BOB
WE DO SO UNDER THE INNOVATIONS
GRANT PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE TO AN
ARTISTIC RESEARCH WITH THE UC
SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR MINDFULNESS
THAT WE JUST RECENTLY GOT THE
REPORT BACK. YET ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM IS FROM
WHAT'S WILL READ BYTES
CONTROLLED TRIAL SO BUT WHAT WE
DID IS WE LOOK AT THREE
DIFFERENT MINDFULNESS
INTERVENTIONS TO LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE WERE DIFFERENCES ACROSS
THOSE THREE. AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE ANY OF THEM HAD ANY
POSITIVE IMPACT ON. CIRCUMVENT
ALL ASPECTS OF THE OFFICERS I AM
JUST A PRELIMINARY REVIEW OF
THAT REPORT. BY THE UC SAN DIEGO
FOUND THAT THE COMBINED
INTERVENTION SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED MEASURES OF AGGRESSION
MOTIONAL REGULATION. DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND STRESS SCORES AND
ORIGINALLY WASN'T A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE DEPENDING ON WHAT
TYPE OF AN INTEREST WHICH USED
THAT MUCH THAT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE
SOME OF THE RESEARCH WE'VE TRIED
TO DO HERE WE'VE TRIED TO DO
AROUND WALLACE. THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF RESEARCH IT'S BEEN DONE
AROUND VARIOUS ASPECTS OF HONEST
I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE IF I CAN SORT
OF. THINK YOU BACK OFF AT WHAT
MR FRANCIA SAID IN RESPONSE
ALEJO IS IT THERE IS NO AGREED
UPON DEFINITION OF WHAT WELLNESS
SETS SILVA COULD INCORPORATE.
MENTAL HEALTH THAT COULD
INCORPORATE EMOTION ALL THE
CUTTING CORPORATE PHYSICAL
HEALTH EVEN WITHIN. EACH OF
THOSE SUBCATEGORIES. THE COULD
BE SPLIT UP RIGHT SO PHYSICAL
COULD BE. A PROGRAM THAT AIMED
AT ASPEN. AT IN REGARDS. RIGHTS
OF THIS IS WHAT L. A. T. DE WHAT
THEY WANT. A THERE WILL PROGRAM
AND LOOKED AT WHAT OR NOT THEY
COULD HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLIENTS.
WILL BE OUT BUT BETTER FOR THAT
ARE COULD BE DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT THAN IF WE'RE LOOKING
AT AN INTERVENTION DESIGNED TO
SPEAK TO YOUR- MENTAL HEALTH AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE LOOKING AT
ISSUES LIKE EMOTIONAL REGULATION
OR DECISION MAKING. OR ITS
IMPACT ON BIAS OR ISSUES AROUND
CITIZENS COMPLAINTS A WHETHER OR
NOT LOWER LEVELS OF.
DEMONSTRATED AND MEASURED
AGGRESSION I HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT. IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
YOU'RE WITH US IN THE TICKET OR
WHATEVER THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
ASPECTS OF COME LOOK OUT SO FAR.
ONE OF MY CONCERNS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT OUTCOME MEASURES AND IT'S
IT IT'S A- WELL MADE POINT TO
THE FAIR CRITICISMS THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER IT IS
THAT WE'RE DOING. BUT THAT WE
HAVE SOME BASIS FOR ENSURING ITS
EFFECTIVENESS. IT AT THE VERY
LEAST DO NO HARM RIGHT WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
INTERVENTIONS ARE. BUT DON'T
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
OFFICERS DON'T HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE AGENCIES DON'T
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES. BOB I THINK BURKE.
I'M JUST CONCERNED IF WE TRY
AND- TALK IN AGGREGATE TERMS AT
THE STATE LEVEL ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD BE THE OUTCOME
MEASRES FOR WELLNESS. THAT THAT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO SORT OF
PARSE OUT I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT REALLY OUR
VISION FOR THIS. PROJECT THIS
PROGRAM. IS POPPING AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP CAPACITY. I THINK
THERE'S CERTAINLY SOME OUTPUTS.
WE COULD GET FROM THERE. BUT ONE
OF THE- THIS IS CHIU DEVELOPED
AT EIGHT. WHILE THE WORKSHOP.
WHICH ARE MODELED. TEAM BUILDING
WORKSHOPS AND THAT'S A PROGRAM
THAT REQUIRES OUR AGENCIES TO
SUBMIT. AFTER ACTION PLANS TO
POST WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE THOSE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THE TYPES OF
INTERACTIONS THAT WERE OFFERED.
IN WOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
SPECIFIC OUTCOME MEASURES FOR
THAT PARTICULAR AGENCY. THE IDEA
LONG TERM FOR US IS TO DEVELOP.
ALMOST LIKE A KNOWLEDGE BANK
WHERE. WE COULD HAVE A SET OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE COULD
OFFER TO OTHER AGENCIES WHO MAY
BE STRUGGLING. WITH A SIMPLE
TYPE OF WELLNESS ISSUE. THAT
WOULD AT LEAST BE ABLE TO OFFER
OF SOME SUPPORT FOR TYPES OF
THINGS THAT SEEM TO WORK WELL
FOR AGENCIES TO BEGIN A SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCE. BY THE
GEOGRAPHICALLY OR RESOURCE WISE-
MAY BE STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME
ISSUE. I'M SORRY I COULD GO INTO
THAT IN MORE DETAIL HAPPY TO IF
IT'S OF ANY BENEFIT TO ANYBODY.
SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND STOP
TALKING DOWN THE TOPPINGS ARE
FOR THE QUESTIONS. I WHICH IS
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK. AT
THE L. A. O.'S- QUITE. AND TRY
TO PUT SOMETHING AROUND THIS I
THINK THE- IDEA THAT OUR BAR IS
DO NO HARM THAN I COULD. NO
MONEY IS ALSO GOING TO DO NO
HARM. AS OF LATE LET'S START
THERE SO THAT CAN BE OUR ONLY.
THAT CAN BE OUR ONLY GOAL AT THE
END THEY DO WE HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIVE AS LEGISLATORS TO OUR
TAX. TO OUR TO OUR TAXPAYERS OUT
THERE TO A CONSTITUENCY THAT OUR
DOLLARS ARE BEING USED IN A WISE
WAY AND THAT. WE ARE GETTING
POSITIVE. RESULTS AND SO I THINK
THE IDEA OF. OF HAVING SOME SORT
OF MEASURING EFFICACY. NEEDS TO
BE DEVELOPED- AND WE COULD
DEVELOP SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS
FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY BUT THIS
IDEA. THAT WILL YOU KNOW LET'S
JUST LEAVE IT AS FLEXIBLE AS
POSSIBLE. AGAIN DOESN'T WORK
WITH WITH THE DUTIES WE HAVE TO
ENSURE TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
USED IN A WAY THAT THAT IS WHY
SAID. RESULTING IN IN POSITIVE-
IN PSITIVE OUTCOMES. ALONG THE
WAY AND SO I HOPE. AS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO ADD
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS OUT
THERE BASED ON EXISTING WELLNESS
TRAINING SOME PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE AND- YOU KNOW. SOME BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE PROBABLY
ALREADY ARE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT.
OUT THERE. AS WELL. IN MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- OKAY WELL IF NOT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR I MEAN I'M
PRESENTING THIS I THINK THE GOAL
OF OFFICER WELLNESS IS THE GOOD
LOFTY GOAL BUT WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE DOING IT IN A
WAY THAT WILL- MISSILES AND REAL
POSITIVE OUTCOMES AND NOT JUST
US. DOWN THE ROAD AND WE SPEND
MILLIONS OR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND HAVE NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT
- AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS ITEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WE HAVE
ISSUES FOR FIVE AND SIX ARE NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS. BUT YOU WANT
TO SEE IF ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THAT BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD.
CAME SEEN NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. OF COURSE
IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT- LET ME
SEE DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. NOPE OKAY SO EACH
PERSON WILL HAVE A TWO ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL NOW TURN TO THE PHONES. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT TO THE
COMMITTEE IS ON THE WEBSITE.
IT'S ALSO ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THIS HEARING BUT JUST
IN CASE THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
. I DON'T. EMBEDDED GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO.
ANCHOR AND THEN WE HAVE KNOWN IN
QUEUE FOR COMMENT. OKAY THE
SCENE WHEN THE KIANA THANK
EVERYBODY INCLUDING AN OPERATOR
FOR BEING WITH US HERE TODAY AND
THAT WILL ENTER INTO THESE
HEARING.